I think Ralph is hitting on me. He'll probably back off since
he knows I'm married, but we'll update if he keeps being weird.
I foresee af allegation in his future.
>> If only she knew. >> Oh, and find like an abused
girl who you could cheat on because she was like cheated on 10
times.
>> I don't understand. I don't know if I just have like
the charisma of a Greek god or if women are just like really
desperate. It's like super easy. >> That was a horrible
decision. I don't know what the you were thinking, but that made
you look like a humongous ass.
So, this started with the Sly Boy drama. Sly boy was the guy
who put the Turkey Tom user her face and like name all over his
video, including in his thumbnail. Okay, he this Sly Boy guy
got a privacy complaint. With a privacy complaint, all you have
to do is remove the offending material and your video doesn't
get taken down, right? You can blur it. You could remove like
the thumbnail.
And he refused to do that. He said he refused to do that. And
then he basically played the victim like, "Oh, YouTube's prosecuting
me and they protect or false accusers in this case." Okay. And
I think this is all very similar to what Mama Max had done back
in the day. So basically, this OP block guy was somebody who
was lying on his behalf to other YouTube creators. Sly boy is
a YouTuber who has had his content taken off the platform multiple
times for violating YouTube's toos or privacy strikes. He usually
follows these videos up with Mama Max styled YouTube is protecting
videos. Despite this guy doxing people, getting close to, if
not over the line in a lot of cases, and doing extremely performative,
engagementbased content, Fali of the OP block decided to back
him up when his video on the Turkey Tom false accuser was taken
down. For those of you who are unaware how privacy complaints
on YouTube work, YouTube basically gives you three options. Contest
the complaint, remove the selected part of your video, or censor
it with a blur. This means that Sly Boy knew at least a day prior
that his video was in violation and didn't do anything to fix
it. This was, of course, so we could do another YouTube protects
these people styled video. After getting rightly shout on for
throwing his weight for this guy, Fali made a follow-up tweet
saying, "I was in the middle of IRL stuff, but I should clarify.
I'm not in support of doxing, been staunchly against it on my
platform and disagreed with it then. What I was referring to
is her continued discussions with the creator about Tom, despite
her apology, could have been clearer." Let's go point by point
here. Fali was not doing IRL stuff. He had enough time to browse
Twitter, make a tweet, and even send the tweet around to people
like Becket to cover on his stream. This also implies he didn't
fully read or understand the sly boy tweet in question. Which
if that's the case, why send it around? >> We love Becket.
Becket is our boy. We love Becket. We love >> a big debate
with Beckett.
>> Oh, did you actually debate with Becket? I just knew
I saw that you were really mad at Becket about probably this
stuff. Yeah, he he DM'd me about me being mad about him, so I
got him to call in. We spoke about it. >> Yeah. Was it
like the last time you guys >> What do you mean?
>> The time you totally screamed at him for >> Oh,
it got it got like that towards the end. It got like that towards
the end a little bit. It wasn't like it was offline cuz obviously
I can't talk like that on stream, but um yeah, it was a little
bit like that. >> And back him up. Obvious answer. Fali
is just lying or he's a sub 30 IQ [__] who can't
comprehend the complexity of a two-s sentence tweet. Last point,
he clearly was not referencing discussions with a creator about
Tom. First off, in what world is this a standard that anybody
has held? Who gives a if she's DMing random content creators
about Turkey Tom? He ends this with a could have been clearer.
Yeah, you could have. Mainly because your stupid tweet has nothing
to do with the DMs that you haven't even seen. Your tweet obviously
reads that it's insane that this video got taken down despite
his ethical content. Whatever the that means. I touched on this
earlier, but I wouldn't call someone who consistently is in violation
of YouTube's policies ethical. But sure. Point is, Opluck is
a spineless liar who instead of just taking the L decided to
do some gay post talk rationalization. And >> why would
you ever dress like this and go on a stream? I just >> Cuz
you're so totally not insecure, man. and you're like just so
not insecure, but actually he's totally not doing it because
he's like trying to pick up a bunch of like queer kids. You'd
think
>> you know, crossdressing is freaking epic and look at
Yahi and all this they do in the ACC.
>> No, it's cuz he's not insecure. It's cuz he's not insecure.
>> Is that what he said? Did he say that? Is that like
a >> Yeah, that's what he says. That's what Becket says
as well. That's what Becky says.
Oh, Val is not insecure. Shut up. Well, there's a there's a thing
where it's like not insecure, but if you're I
am sorry. If you're like a 400 lb woman, you could not be insecure
and wear like a string bikini, but ain't nobody want to see that.
Ain't you should you shouldn't be doing that. You're actually
directing harassment towards yourself by doing that. >> Now,
if Liam was dressed like this,
>> stop with the
people need to stop. People need to stop >> with the over
>> first. No, first. No. No, no, not everybody. First,
he needs to stop. Okay, he is doing it to himself, but then everyone
else needs to stop, too, cuz it's >> we're not stopping
until he stops.
>> He's got to stop face. He holds no strong principles
or morals, and it makes complete sense to me that this guy is
hardlocked with a ACC audience who can't drool out a single coherent
thought without some parasocial daddy telling them what to think.
So, keep crossdressing on your streams, Fali. I'm sure it makes
your wife's boyfriend really happy to see you expose yourself
live for your audience. Jesus Christ.
>> Not his wife, by the way. That's a kind of a key thing
here.
>> What's that? >> Not his wife. >> Oh, not
his wife. Okay, fair enough. >> He actually left his wife
for this. >> Cool. Awesome.
Do we have uh What? Where does this go next? >> He lies
about the sly boy stuff. He's wrong. He's wrong about the sly
boy stuff and he copes about it and lies he's busy in real life
and all this >> There are more lies there. I know. I've
seen some blogs that show that there's like more lies there actually.
Like it's actually a more lie than it even seems >> So
he says he's against doxing and against mass reporting and all
this stuff, but then in private moral shows some stuff where
he's
um supporting he he's encouraged people to mass report Westside
Tyler
and ah >> he's supporting the doxing of Rowan
or Sacramento. I mean I'm doing it now. I'm [__]
[__] of Sacramento. the uh the tacky Tom as he's
like supporting that. He's saying, "Yeah, I don't I don't think
she should be I think she should be able to get away from it.
Everyone should know. Everyone should know some stupid like that.
I can't remember being like a total loser." And
so so he's lying about that. So those those are two kind of lies.
That kind of sucks though. That's not like a huge thing. It's
kind of relevant to the initial point, but it's not really what's
funny. The funny stuff is what Moral starts releasing
uh after
that happens. So basically >> it's sort of shown that he's
like a total hypocrite that he's like a liar. >> And then
moral starts finding I believe so if I remember correctly it's
something like the mods or something of the Discord that Fali
is in. They start sending morale like private chat room stuff
like either mod chat or something like that. We'll get to where
all this is coming from. We'll get to where all that's coming
from. >> So, first things first, right? So, this is this
where we'll take it first.
this is all to do while while this is all coming out of the Sly
Boy stuff really and Fouchy have sort of like a longunning
rivalry, a longunning feud,
uh that this is just ignited around a competition perhaps. >> Yeah.
Uh, and there's a few examples
of this
where, so for instance, here we can see FGI looking very upset
when someone joins
uh his stream with a moral styled avatar on. See? So, let's just
pull this up. Let's pull this up. Pulling it up. >> Sure.
And um uh yeah, take your time. Get it get it done when it's
done. who who uh >> Oh, that is way more morow styled than
I expected. I was like, "What the is literally just morally?"
>> Hey, Ash. What's up? OH MY GOD, IT'S Embra Ash. What's
up, Emil Ash?
>> you actually >> You want to talk about You want
to talk about dog words?
>> Ash. Ash, we've talked about this.
>> I don't understand what we've done. >> Too hard.
So when he says we've talked about this,
>> they've spoke about how they should don't reference
moral on stream. That's like a thing they don't want. He doesn't
want moral referenced. He doesn't want the Twitter account conspiracy
lemur referenced. Uh he he's very
uh controlling over what topics get brought up on stream. So
So this ash person comes in >> is a real piece of >> Yeah.
real real piece of work that this uh Ash person comes in with
a row person a row persona
>> uh starts making jokes and Fouchi is immediately like
Ash
we talked about this he's like very
you >> yeah I can hear it yeah >> controlling nervous
>> it's it's uh
>> coming through so I mean you might just play that from
I think he is a little bit I rateate for for a minute or two
>> do we have a a viewership count on this VOD from before
this.
3.8K views on a 30 on a 5 hour VOD. That's what 3 to 400 concurrent
viewers. That's a lot of >> ACC stuff. And he got in with
the ACC crowd and that stuff does draw a lot of people in when
it's uh
when you're in the mix. Like the J stuff when when I was in that
was >> drawing loads of loads of views. Same with Chud
when he was doing it. >> Damn. This is this is this is
>> you lose your soul by being in it for too long.
>> Seems to be the case. >> You retro you literally
you retroactively get as a child by being in the ACC for too
long. This is a thing. >> It's just there's something in
the air. It's just it's like contagious. Yeah.
>> This is this is this is Oh boy. This is >> I'm
sorry.
This is so adorable. I had to make one.
>> Isn't it like Isn't it like a stop? It's literally him.
It's not. Isn't it like a >> Is she So, how else How else
am I supposed to interpret this other than she's doing this explicitly
to with this
>> I don't think so. I don't think so. I think there are
just women all around Fouchy that are just falling in love with
Mor. I think that's what's happening here. >> Listen,
uh the the Zomboid opener, okay, kind of undefeated, okay? Hey,
want to play Zomboid with me?
If only >> we don't know it was that easy the whole
That's how easy it is to find women guys. Hey, want to play Project
Zomboido with me? >> Stock thing. This is not even on MRO.
I actually have like a real question for people who may know.
>> I don't know. >> Okay. Uh, we got more. We We
continue on with this one. >> No, we keep going on this
one. No, >> probably all we need. Um,
>> where's So, I think I've got Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, I've
got I've got the relevant message here. So, so this is
the relevant stuff. Pull this up
>> Okay. Okay. Who's Cloudy real quick? Was she on the
call here? >> That's uh Fouchi's main partner that you
just saw in the >> Ah, so this would be Oh, I close Doomer
Media, but the the thing that was on Doomer Media, that video
there, right? Like the partner who was in the room with him.
>> Yes. Yes. >> Okay, got it. Hey, you got a sec?
Yes. Okay. I don't actually like playing HR, but I know FalG
asked you not to use the morale Fuji on his stream. Please respect
what he asked for his uh what he asked for his channel. Someone
came into chat trying to get Fal to say something racial over
it, and that's made it too uncomfortable for me not to say something,
too. You could do whatever you want and be on anyone's stream
on your time tonight. Uh on your time. Tonight was just a lot
for me, and I couldn't let it sit in my chest. I hope you understand.
Oh my god, I'm sorry. I don't remember Fouchy asking that. Oh,
I see. Well, and then we go to this one. How was Ash's part of
the stream? Blank. Yep. Blank. They were asked not to use the
round pick several times. Blank. The last uh the last op stream
they did it made some of uh they did it made some of his racist
come and try to get FJI to say a racial slur.
>> Is that really do we really believe that that's what
the issue is?
that morale is so racist, so incredibly racist that his presence
on a stream even as an avatar for another person is causing people
to come in and say
right now. >> Something bunch of Nazi Nazi
Ralph fans.
>> Wow. A lot of these people apparently
just name the
Q's hood ornament. We're literally just talking. I know, but
y'all have brought up moral on stream once I once when I say
no. So
blank blank. I was agreeing with you, Pooky. I mentioned moral
once weeks ago.
Uh okay. Oh >> yeah. Very nervous, very nervous, controlling,
anxious guy we're seeing here.
So that's there. Now
we get the mod call. Do you need to see the mod call is probably
the first lengthy piece of content. Do you? So, if we want to
just watch something,
it's the first place to go.
Now,
>> it's not the funniest stuff. That's the >> We
find Can we Do you want to link it and we can watch like a little
bit of it, get like a sort of flavor for who the mods are, what
they're talking about, and then you could just explain to me
where it goes. >> Yeah, we may skip through a little bit
as well. I may try to look through the transcript while we're
watching some of
>> cool. All right. So, I just wanted to talk real quick
uh just because there's like some changes in the Discord, things
like that. Currently, we we have enough mods.
So, I'm going to make the decision to start relieving people
of mod duties cuz I don't think the ops and and other staff things
need to be doing mods. So, we're going to be shifting things
>> Oh, if you can >> because like priorities have
shifted, stuff like that. Probably a bit of context that's missing
here is that the op block is was never just it was never just
FGI initially. It was a sort of community channel. It was like
a group channel. It was uh meant to be
a YouTuber called FPS Diesel. He had a research team and they
set up a channel together that was called the Odd Block and Fi
joined it. I don't think he was a founding member. He joined
it and has become the face of it over the past year or so.
>> Okay.
Interesting.
I did sort of know that the OP block was a group channel, but
I think like do you want to continue on from here or I I know
there's something about basically he's forced other people out
of this, right? >> Yeah. So, that's what what we're going
to hear here. This is really this is like a firing call. So,
everyone in this call is either an unpaid moderator,
a co-host, or like someone that does work on the channel, like
thumbnails, research, stuff like that. Now, pretty I, as far
as I understand it, most of the people here have received some
kind of payment from the project at some point. So, they are,
you know, doing work for it and have been involved. You know what
I mean? It's not just they're not just moderators, they're sort
of involved, too.
Okay. All right. And we have a dedicated mod team. So you guys
don't have to mod anymore and we're just going to shift some
things. So
>> So when it comes to that, so we're going to be just
alleviating mod roles. So if you don't see the mod team stuff,
that's pretty much why it's probably easier. Cloudy is in charge
of the Discord anyways. That's been her role for a period of
time. And uh Be has been very gracious to set up the bots. Uh
Z has been on top of it as well. Uh Salt has been on top of it.
and uh Potato has been actually great uh tracking a lot of the
and stuff like that that come from other circles and things like
that. So, we're going to be doing that. So, if you guys see things
transition out, that's pretty much why we created a staff role
obviously. Um so, if there's any staff stuff like the editing
or YouTube thumbnails that we do in that Discord, um it's going
to be there obviously if stuff and research happens in this Discord.
Um still going to exist still going to exist that way moving
forward. So, you're going to see things like shift around and
all that nonsense. Um I also believe if I remember correctly
uh your uh for people who have individual channels uh like I
know um Q you and Ash have talked about doing individual channel
stuff um and kind of bringing about the cynical report. Your
stuff's still going to be open. Your stuff is still going to
be there. Uh certain perms will just change. Uh it's just kind
of the way it is. But we're just trying to consolidate parts
of the Discord a little bit better. So we kind of separate how
things work. You know, it's just kind of how it is. Everyone
has new responsibilities.
um and uh things that kind of take precedence over that if there
How big is this Discord? Do you have any idea?
>> Not big enough to justify this.
>> I cuz I've I've had at one point like a really really
really big Discord and I've never I don't think I've ever even
had a private mod call before.
>> Yeah. No, I've never had a a mod call. >> 463
people. So my Discord and it's contracted significantly. My Discord
got pretty close to 5,000 members at one point. I've never done
a public mod call or sorry, a private mod call. I've done a public
thing before where it was like me talking to people about the
Discord, but that was like in a public channel as like one time.
I don't even know. This is crazy. This is a crazy level to go
to for a Discord or responsibilities that you no longer want
anymore uh due to either personal uh um like personal responsibilities
or like you're just not feeling it anymore. Please let me know.
I don't like realistically speaking um friendship is paramount
over uh over staff responsibilities. But the reality is is that
I would like to take the channel in a more uh positive uh trajectory
as well as a more professional trajectory. And regardless of
that, if it affects friendships and relationships, I'd rather
just nip it in the bud and say, "Hey, um thank you for being
around kind of thing. Thank you for doing what you do. Take the
responsibilities you want. Don't take the responsibilities that
you don't
Um, seems very strange to have a call like this. Yeah, I don't
He's like basically telling people that he's taking mod perms.
I don't know what the friend thing is about.
>> So, the thing is it's not just mod perms. That's the
thing is it's like they're basically being totally iced out.
They're basically most of them can't come on stream anymore.
He's not hiring them for stuff anymore. They're not mods anymore.
He's basically icing them out,
but he's trying not to say
Okay.
I is that going to become obvious from people asking questions
and uh >> Yeah. Yeah. It doesn't become totally obvious.
Sorry, it's obvious. It doesn't become explicit in this call.
Uh there's a there's a later call where FPS Diesel confronts
him where that becomes more explicit and obvious.
>> Do we want to go to that? Do we think like is there
some moment in here that is important to capture? >> Uh
we go through this. >> Yeah, there's a couple moments.
So,
let me just pull this up real quick. One second. So, where's
>> I'm going to let So, so some things are going to change.
Um, and that's like, >> do you know like what specifically
is going to change? Like, is there anything that we need to change
or that we >> No, no. Everything on the Discord side, uh,
Cloudy and myself will take care of. Um, so you don't have to
worry about that. So, none none of that stuff is. >> FPS
Diesel and Valy listen to this call while they're in their call.
Someone is what someone says.
Yeah, but you're not going to want to sit through a few moments
here.
>> Let's go to um
about 14 minutes and watch for like 5 minutes there. That's that's
really where stuff we want. >> Yeah. As long as uh yeah,
as long as um
long as Fi keeps getting what he needs to so we can he can finish
paying off the artists. Like that's why >> and that's >> we're
pressing so hard for donuts and stuff. But um I don't have anything
else. So >> Yeah, that's pretty much it. I think we're
good. So move. >> So yeah. Yeah. So pause there. Sorry
if you just heard that. >> She says, "So we we're pushing
for Donos so FA can pay the money for the artists, >> artists
and stuff." Yeah. He's commissioned more art than he can pay
for. And that's like there is a lot of issues with unpaid work
floating around that don't Yeah. They're not the focus of any
of this, but there are there are just like, you know,
people have had issues getting payment basically
at various points.
Uh, okay. Yeah. Yeah. I've I've heard this as well that basically
they're like pushing for donations for mods and that it's not
necessarily the case that the donations went to sorry, not mods,
artists. And it's not necessarily the case that the donations
went to the artists first. Like I think they were they taking
donations and like paying their own bills first and then trying
to >> I've got the DM about that somewhere. So >> doesn't
change anything. Again, if you have obligations and like >> I
assume we keep listening for a little bit. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Yeah.
recreational obligations, but lower or personal obligation, but
kind of just be honest about it. Um, makes my life a little bit
easier. >> Like like I said, if if I if I can't do something
one week or or or something, I'll I'll let you know.
>> Admittedly, I would I would like to be able to do more
help more if I could. I >> we we have enough like like
I'm being like absolutely serious. Uh we have enough help.
>> You got the mods and I was like, "Oh, I don't have to
do anything." >> Yeah, we have enough and we have people
who are really enthusiastic and really want to do this this stuff.
I kind of want to loop back to what I said before. Um, I just
I really took it to heart when uh when you guys said I was being
kind of really pushy about like the channel stuff and pushy about
moderating and pushy about XY and Z and I realized that my mistake
with that was I should have just asked if you wanted to do it
in the first place and I realized looking back on it I never
did that. I just assumed that you wanted to do it. So I corrected
that. I am not going to ask you guys again. We have enough. I
have everything I need for right now. If I do need your help,
I will DM you. But as of now, you guys just focus on your own
games or your own channel. uh the D and D stuff. I know it's
going to go really well once it's all put together. I'm genuinely
very excited. Um I dropped out, but that doesn't mean I'm not
going to watch. I'm like I said, I'm really hyped for the game.
>> Um yeah, like I said, I I took it to heart and I took
it to heart and I um adjusted, so everything's going to be good.
I found someone who's really good with bots and who can help
me hammer down hammer down some of this stuff. >> So, uh
we're good. >> Do you all want still want me doing research
for you guys? >> I that's again uh that is completely up
to you. That's something that you still want to do. >> Um
I still enjoy it. I'm just I I don't know if I'm meeting your
guys' expectations with that. >> I mean, listen, >> there
there hasn't been a big thing or anything to like to point you
towards
deep dive needed for anything. >> Yeah, there's no real
deep dive and stuff like that. Um
the the one thing I will say is just kind of be realistic. Um
you
>> Okay. Yeah, that's okay. Um
>> I know I'll be I'll be blunt. You guys I love you guys.
You guys are my friends. But the reality is is that uh our time
obligations have changed. Uh as as as
happy as that makes me that that has expanded our friend group,
that also affects certain parts of the channel and that's fine.
But that's the whole point of getting other people available.
Um because like specifically for mod stuff uh and things like
that, it's been it's been nice having some of the newer mods
as well because people like Z, Salt, and Potato know that I don't
ever know >> and they're up at all the crazy times. >> Yeah.
These are people these are people that are go from commentary
hell like the people that will just dox you for fun
all the way to the biggest channels around and they're just these
are everywhere. So, we have a nice mix of mods who are everywhere
to mods who are just focused on us. So, I think that that's fine.
When it comes to research, like just, you know, things like that
is is there's nothing to really point us at yet. If that does
come a time in place, we will do the same thing that we've always
done. We will point each other and we will try to do the best
that we can. Again, the channel just has to run when I'm at work
cuz this is not my full-time job. Um, >> like truthfully,
it's not our fulltime job. No, >> it's not our full-time
job. >> Yeah, I know. >> These guys still think they're
on the team. That's fine. >> And and you know, I I still
have school obligations and like that. So I
>> my question is I guess it's more for me. It might also
apply to Ash. I'm not sure. Um
is there a number of
streams in which you'd like us to be able to be available to
co-host?
>> Because that's kind of like my thing right now is I'm
relegated to co-host when I can. >> There's there's no
as it stands. If you are available, you are available. If you're
not, you're not. >> Okay. I know. I just >> What?
Am I allowed to co-host? >> Are you still working for Malcolm?
>> So, okay. Okay, let's let's stop right there. Pause
right there. >> Malcolm FPS Diesel. >> No, no. FT
FT Mongoose.
>> FT Mongoose. >> You remember that person? FT Mongoose.
>> Um, Godamn it, Malcolm.
>> Um, it was it was about the Poppy and Zena stuff. It
was Do you remember the Poppy and Zena thing where >> like
Malcolm and Stardust? They were like, you know, it was like kind
of like they obviously did some stuff wrong and this person was
a parent and like trans person. Obviously was a good parent,
a mentally ill freak and all this stuff, but like you know, they
were really blown out of proportion cuz this was like an adult
kid that was a total
>> Yeah. I remember how stupid it was. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. >> So, um, god damn it Malcolm and Fi
hate each other. Well, God damn it. I don't know if god damn
Malcolm like super hates value but god god damn it Malcolm as
far as I understand as far as uh Becky is explaining to me uh
has has sort of a similar relationship to Becky and and Fali
as I do where some criticisms well not with Fi for me but you
know same as Becky uh some criticisms but says them in a very
mean way and it causes a lot of bad blood in the communities
but it's not actually that that deep but Fi takes a really really
to heart. Um, >> well, that's what he opened this up with,
right? This is going to be a more positive place. So that he's
going to argue that basically your association to this person
makes it you not a positive person. So you you're not going to
be allowed on the stream.
>> Nope. Nope. Nope. The arguments are even worse, bro.
The arguments far worse. >> So let's just let's just rewind
like 10 seconds. You got that bit of context. Let's just listen
listen through. >> There's no as it stands. If you are
available, you are available. If you're not, you're not. >> I
know. I just
>> Am I allowed to co-host?
>> Are you still working for Malcolm >> straight
up?
>> because that that was >> You were working for
Malcolm. >> I was He like had me do thumbnails once in
a while. That's about it. >> Mhm. Cuz I as as you and I
discussed privately and I reached out to Malcolm as well. Uh,
I
didn't want your association with the channel to directly impact
any monetary services that you are going to receive through him.
I made that very clear with him. I mean, he takes pot shots at
me all the time. I don't really give a [__] I I I
hope he suffers the worst kind of bad shroom strip in his life.
My man does LSD on a daily and shows. >> Crazy. That's
crazy. >> What do you think he goes?
He may be sober, but you're telling me he only goes sober to
those concerts. I don't believe that. But that's just me.
>> so he's seething him, right? He's like seeing him. >> Yeah.
Not relevant to anything, but >> Like for like no reason.
>> Yeah. Cool. Well, here's what I want. >> Yeah.
So, let's let's see those DMs quickly. The DMs where he's saying
he reached out to Malcolm. Uh, let's see if he's keeping that
energy when he's talking to to Malcolm here. >> Okay. So,
that was Ash who was talking there, right? Important to know
that it was it was Ash who was he asked about there. Are you
still working with Malcolm, right? >> Yep. Yep. Yep. >> Because
Ash is somebody who's going to be relevant to this whole thing.
Hey, just reaching out because it's my understanding that Ash,
Eric's Blue, has done some thumbnail work for you in the past.
I want to clarify that any disagreements and coverage you and
I may have, I hope have no effect on their potential work for
you. Ash is a friend, and I don't want this to interfere with
anything that you had planned for them to work on. And I also
wanted to make it clear to you that I have no want or intent
to impact the product of your channel. I just wanted to be open
because I think this level of transparency is essential. Thank
you.
this literally does nothing. This is
>> I just want you to know that this person's my friend.
I I almost feel like it's the opposite, right? >> You're
not feel like it's the opposite. >> You're saying this
so that it might cause a problem.
>> And not only that, but there's a a game being played
here. I feel like cuz he says, "I I'm going to make sure I has
no I have no want or intent to impact the product of your channel,
but you're making it so there's an ultimatum. You work for me
or you work for Malcolm. You co-host on my show or you work for
Malcolm." So, you can say, "I'm not trying to affect the product,
your channel. I'm never going to tell them to do something about
the product, your channel, but you're telling them they can't
do that if they're going to do the stuff with you. You're putting
them in a position where they have to choose." And so, obviously,
you are actually doing something to impact. you're essentially
trying to force some kind of exclusivity
there, right? And
it it doesn't really there's no like real reason for that. It's
just like paranoia basically. It's like you won't be controlling
over your friend group. >> Um h is it always controlling?
I guess it would it would depend. I think what you do here is
you just like
if you feel like probably if you feel like this person like hates
you, the
the mongoose person, if you feel like they hate you, you just
say like, "Um,
I'm I'm good with you." I I think you just say, "I don't want
you as a co-host." You don't like make it a ultimatum, right?
Like if that's actually where it is, you >> Yeah. Sure.
Sure. Exactly. Yeah. You would just say you just say straight
up like they You don't say, "Oh, if you're going to work for
them, I'm not going for me." But if they say, "No, I don't want
you as co-host." You say, "Oh, you're not saying, "Yeah, forgot."
If you're working with them, you >> I don't care. It's
just a thing. It's a decision you make. You never You would never
try and coersse the decision out of them. That's That's the point
where it's like >> you're playing a game. >> Yeah.
And it is It is kind of rough where it's,
how would you put it? It's kind of rough when you are explicitly
saying like when you're saying, "I'm not doing anything, but
you are explicitly doing something, right? Like, I don't want
to [__] with this person, but you are explicitly
>> trying to do something."
Yeah, there's a small DMs there as well. >> Say, yeah,
>> Mongoose follows up. Oh, not at all. I have no issues
with you. Lol. I've said that many times. All good. Same on my
end. No worries at all. Even if I did hate you, I still can have
Ash make me thumbnails. Lol.
Doggy a month later messages him, I guess. No, three, four months
later. >> Yeah, I don't know what whether that's relevant,
but obviously we don't have that message, but yeah. >> Okay.
All right. Funny. >> Um, funny stuff. >> So, yeah.
So, that's doesn't quite line up, I don't think. doesn't I feel
already we're seeing here this guy's being a little bit deceptive
be play a bit more that video or multicool they're still working
for him I would respectfully say no um the biggest reason why
like I said before I do not want an impact monetarily and people
are going to start asking you if you are in specific spaces
I I'm just going to be blunt it's just not going to work out
>> for you >> it's not going to work out the way
you're going to you think it's going to work out
>> cuz those people will have no chill like straight up
those people have no chill
and I've learned that and I've learned that the hard way that
those people >> sort of like
it's it's also like clearly a personal problem for him and he's
externalizing it and making it about like well here's like here's
how other people will react and that won't be good for you right
he's trying to make it like a concern for the other person like
the thing he wants for himself he's trying to express that in
terms of how he's concerned for the well-being of another person
like I I find that particularly gross in a lot of situations
when you're like listen I'm not going to tell like
you know I would do I you're my friend I'd do anything for But
I just don't think this is going to be a good look for you. It's
like you're asking them to do something that explicitly benefits
you and basically not doesn't benefit them at all or even inconveniences
them. I think it's like just a gross way to manipulate people.
Especially when it's this transparent.
All right, we keep continue on with the mod call. >> Yeah.
Yeah, for now. >> Yeah, got it. Um, but that's just pretty
much it. Uh, again, >> making it is making it is completely
fine. Uh, not being able to make it also completely fine. I don't
particularly care. We do like a lot of D and D. So >> yeah,
we're we're also I mean listen, you guys have a lot of D and
D stuff. >> Well, yeah, I was just going to say at this
point like it seems I mean I don't know. I don't really look
at uh much of the other servers anymore. I kind of just even
before I got more busy, I just assume you guys seem to have like
a game every day. Um if you guys uh are free for stream, you
could either DM. Honestly, it' probably be better if FG DMs you
if he wants you for a stream. Um otherwise you can DM him if
you're in waiting or something. But I have I've adjusted the
rules already. And like I said, if you guys just uh the only
I guess not even an obligation because I'm not again I'm not
gonna I'm not asking you do everything on your own time. Whatever
you guys need to do. Uh just I'm looking forward to seeing Ash
and Q take on your guys' own channel stuff. I think it would
be really interesting. >> And then like for KJ, like I
said, >> dude, I think I have I told ever told you that
um was at a company where there was like a layoff taking place
and I was a part of the layoff, but they were addressing the
layoff to the whole company. And the way the CEO like expressed
that people were being fired is he says, "We we we had to go
ahead and transition people back to the community is the way
he described it." And we all just laughed and me'd on this guy
for like the rest of the time we were all at that company. We
have to transition people back to the community. It's just like,
bro, are you serious? Are you serious right now? So funny. Okay.
And that's what that just sounded like. I'm so excited to have
you guys like work on your own channels. >> Yeah, that's
what that's what the whole call is. Obviously, we're not watching
all of it, but yeah, basically the whole thing is every the read
that literally everyone comes away from uh comes away with from
this is it sounds like the worst teams meeting ever. is like
the worms worst teams like redundancy meeting ever. Like you
just
>> like you basically HR people are are trained to only
say positive things and so when they have to lay people off they're
just like trying to figure out a positive way to say I'm just
excited for you to be able to chase like new opportunities all
over the place. Like it's so crazy. I'm almost jealous of you
getting fired cuz like I wish I was in your position and could
like go and chase my dreams. We're letting you chase your dreams.
>> Very funny stuff. focus on the D and D game. Uh, I'm
really looking forward to it. It's going to look really good.
Like the stuff that Blue talks about has been really interesting.
>> Yeah. So, we have to We can't just jump in the live
anymore is basically >> No, I'm making I made it so most
people >> Okay.
Um, I was going to say, >> does nobody just go Wait, isn't
what why doesn't Faly just make his own thing that isn't the
OP block so that he can do his own solo streams? >> Does
nobody say that to him here? They don't go, "Hey, why is this
guy taking over our group channel?" They sort of >> I guess
not. No, no one puts their foot down. Right. >> They all
sort of avert their eyes and are like, "Oh, well, okay." >> Yeah.
So, so I mean, well, I mean, we probably move to the next part
now. I think we'll do this part next. We'll do the diesel part
next. So, after this happens, after they all get uh made redundant
in this in this Discord call, um
they're sort of speaking about it and it ends up Diesel ends
up catching wind of it. Obviously, a lot of these people work
with Diesel and know Diesel and he ends up catching and they
all play D and D together. He catches wind of it and decides
to go and confront Fouchy. So we we have that that call that
>> Awesome.
Vali call with FPS 1st September 2025.
>> I saw some people watching this. I think I saw you watching
this earlier tonight.
>> Yo, what's up? >> What's up? You know, I'm just
calling you. Uh I just want to kind of like give you some updates
on some things that are happening that I guess are now out of
my control. Um and kind of just keep you a breast on a couple
different things. Uh, dude, what the is happening with the stomach
on this? >> Why does he always speak like HR? Dude, >> I
can't look away from this. What is this? What is happening? >> It's
his goblin OC. His Goblin Dungeons and Dragons OC. Bro, >> guess
are now out of my control. >> Uh, hold on. >> Give
you some updates on some things that are happening that I guess
are now out of my control. Um, and kind of just keep you a breast
on a couple different things. Um, so,
uh, yesterday,
um, internally I had swapped some of the staff roles specifically
for Ash, KJ, and Q. Just the reason being is, uh, they're not
as focused on the channel as they used to be. With Ash is completely
fine because a specifically for mod rolling stuff. They still
had staff rolls and things like that. Um, I was texted this morning
regarding the fact that KJ was removed from Cop's mod team. I
have nothing to do with
>> Uh, I spoke with KJ. I spoken with Becket about it.
Uh, it appears that KJ's mods don't I mean, excuse me, uh, Becket's
mods don't like KJ. Wait, hold on
real quick. This is, let's just be real. This is like a a side
channel or something for
Copen, right? Yeah. seen that went back out. Yeah. >> Okay.
All right. >> Um and it was like a purity test thing
and I just guess that people are just dropping from the channel
which is fine but I wanted to make you aware. Uh I am assuming
based on uh my understanding of it since I've been removed. I
assume Hal is the one that removed me from her >> Uh how
removed you from her server? >> Yeah, she removed me from
the server which is completely fine. I understand that she's
going to choose sides and I'm not I I'm not here to play stupid.
I know that if
uh if things are being said about me behind my back uh specifically
by specific people. Um it is uh I know who she's going to choose.
That was never going to bother me. Uh I guess Q has now left
my server as well as the private op server. >> Uh I don't
know what's happen. Killjoy has dropped out as DM apparently.
So that's a thing that I have to deal with. I know that Killjoy
guy now. Little perturbed because I had the discussion with KJ
today that I specifically
um didn't want that to happen that I was that he was keeping
all of his perms the way that he always had it. It was just a
um I was giving a
uh a thing.
and that's kind of just what it is. Uh I I don't know. I my my
annoyance is I give people uh an opportunity to speak, but I'm
a little I'm a little perturbed because it feels like I'm always
extending the hand to figure out things that are going on. Uh
but nothing happens. And uh
like I get it if Killjoy doesn't want to do the DM stuff anymore.
Uh he asked me today if he could start his own channel. I actually
encouraged it. I came back to him with the idea cuz he said,
"Oh, can I use some of the stuff that was members content?" And
I said, "Yeah, you know, that's a great idea." I came back to
him cuz I was a little iffy on it.
>> So KJ, the person that when they're saying KJ, it's
Killjoy the whole time, >> Killjoy guy. >> Okay.
Okay. >> In the beginning. And I was like, you know what?
You're absolutely right. When the when the program goes out,
start putting that stuff on your channel and I'll remove it from
my channel. So I I don't I'm just g keeping you a breast
listen, if do you want me can I can kind of be honest for a second?
>> Uh, sure. What's up? It's like the second time he said
I'm I'm just trying to keep you a breast of the situ I don't
know. I just don't hear people use that word a lot. Um
I don't appreciate
the kind of the that I've been getting and it's not you. It's
not even just
I don't appreciate the fact that if they came into my server
and
I they asked me a channel question, they kind of have to go through
how I don't appreciate that. That's happened multiple times.
And again, I don't hate >> Wait, can you So,
>> it's the same thing. It's the same thing she does to
you. >> What do you mean? >> No. No.
>> No. No. Drama. I don't listen to drama talk. And it
happened in my server the other day. KJ asked me a question and
KJ's like, "Oops, let me ask how >> because you were like
talking shop and >> she's talking shop and she doesn't
like it." And again, I don't care about that. It's just no one
is being personally no one's being honest with me and it's very
>> about so about >> can you clarify like what's
going on? So Hal is another person who's in the op block, one
of the researchers for FBSD. >> Yeah. So basically it it's
just um
the the specifics here don't matter a whole lot because it's
it's like none of this actually matters. It is literally just
FI coming up with reason. >> I just want to know why it's
that's all
>> like I want to be able to intuit it. I want to be able
to understand that. So I'm just wondering who person is. >> Oh
man, what was this part of it? It's
>> I think this person was
trying to moderate the Discord in a way he didn't like. One minute.
Let me Yeah. Yeah. One minute. Just could you do play? I'm getting
answer. I'm getting
>> Okay. She's talking shop, but she doesn't like it. And
again, I don't care about that. It's just no one is being personally.
No one's being honest with me. And it's very >> about so
about that >> what they what what they want to do with
the channel.
And that and that does greatly upset me because I had nothing
to do because like this is this is feeling like there have been
talks behind my back.
>> And I don't do that to other people.
>> it's it's just greatly annoying. >> Oh. Oh, okay.
Yeah. Yeah. I think I'm pretty sure that's what's going on. So
I think
there in the D&D chat or something there's drama talk happening
and the how person doesn't want it to happen cuz they don't want
to be involved in the drama stuff and then Fi Fi feels like >> other
people have to ask if it's okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Work around it. >> Um to like talk
about drama and it's not Yeah. Yeah. I think that kind of makes
sense. I think you're kind of getting it >> Yeah. Yeah.
And Vali is basically saying that like
basically he feels like it's being brought up somewhere else
or
uh hold on >> that's what he's saying but really what's
what's more happening here I think is basically
uh how it's like a
BI's in these relationships for his career. This guy's obviously
you know he's not only there he's there to try and get standing.
He's there for standing and he's trying to social climb and so
he's there really to to car D and D but also to try and talk
to people like Diesel about drama and try and increase his standing
there and so >> he's what he's really upset about here
while he's saying it's about people talking about his back or
whatever I don't do those people obviously does though uh
>> is what he's really upset about is the inability to
use >> people are this >> yeah he's getting
yeah he's he's getting and uh he's trying to get a closer relationship
with Diesel, but these people are like more Diesel's friends,
I think.
>> I got it. Got it. Got it. >> What what they want
to do with the
>> And that and that does greatly upset me because I had
nothing to do because like this is this is feeling like there
have been talks behind my back.
>> And I don't do that to other people.
>> It's it's just greatly annoying. Again, I don't this
is this is me saying I have no issues with how I just want to
make it very clear. I just don't like anyone was upront with
me. >> Yeah, if people don't want to
I mean, yeah, there they're like spaces to talk drama and then
spaces not to. I like having like a a place to turn off from
it too. Personally, like I've sometimes I've hopped in a VC and
like KJ or Q or somebody will be like, "Yo, do you hear about
that?" >> When Fi raised this point, he said, "How's doing
the same thing to me that she did to you?" Uh, and now Diesel
saying, "Well, I actually like having that space to not talk
about drama."
>> Yeah. He's like, he's like tried to appeal to Diesel,
to get Diesel on side there, and it's just totally, totally >> Off
the clock right now. I do not care. And then they're like, "Okay,
Diesel." And then they stop. >> Um, just cuz I I'm just
not in a mood or whatever. Um,
>> people just have different levels of tolerance for it.
Some people can >> enjoy it all the time, but I know I
need to shut off from it. Cool. >> But um >> yeah,
it's working
backwards from from this to I mean Yeah, I Okay, I I cars on
the table. I didn't know about this.
>> cuz of course I did. I was kind of waiting for you to
come to me. Um >> yeah, I spoke with Becca this morning
and he told me that you two spoke >> uh that Becket and
I spoke >> uh previously about a message, but so I'm assuming
the others have told you. Uh yeah. Well, I I've gotten filled
in on everything that
happened. So, I heard you had like a
ops meeting and you were like, "Okay, so you took away the mod
roles, right?" Which is fine. And I think that's completely agreeable
>> and okay, I don't disagree with that ruling at all.
Um, and then but the problem is is that like while doing that
you were not like explicitly but like implicitly like showing
them the door being like
>> if there's something you want to do I encourage you
to go do it with your own thing kind of. >> Okay. Well,
here's >> very transparently. Yes. >> The thing they
keep talking about it and it never happens. >> I have been
promised movie nights. I have been like like Ash did movie nights
stopped happening for D and D games. >> Uh Q wanted to
do >> Did you express
>> What is that supposed to help somehow or >> Yeah,
because they were promised a movie night. He wasn't getting them.
>> I am not doing that anymore. Perfectly honest, people
are autonomous adults. >> Mhm. Um, so I I can't keep Sorry
to cut you off, but I I am I am personally very tired of being
overly communicative and asking if they have the ability to do
that cuz Ash said that she wasn't that they were unable to do
it, which is fine. I didn't really give a [__] about
>> But like my whole thing is, okay, like Q for instance,
Q, >> why did you bring it up? >> Begs me to do something.
And I said, hey, do something. And then it just doesn't happen.
Mhm. >> He constantly says that he's going to do something
and it just doesn't happen.
>> What am I supposed I I I can't
What? What? I don't understand. What is this? What is the relation
between this and the like going on the stream like doing the
group stream?
>> Oh, these guys didn't do additional things in the Discord
that make the group stream work better or make a bigger community.
>> Yeah. So, so you don't get to come on the group stream
anymore. It's like, dude, what? That's not That can't be how
that works. I can't force him to do
>> Uh, with KJ, KJ has been fine. Um, I mean, he was off
research stuff. They weren't really modding. That's completely
fine. There hasn't been really any stories, but again, I haven't
been calling him a snake behind the scenes, which is what I've
been told. He's been called behind the scenes. >> Yeah,
I think that comes from Beckett's mod team or whatever. >> Yeah,
a lot of them don't like them. There are also chatters that don't
like them either. Um, they feel very uncomfortable. Uh, you know,
Lord to throw this guy under the bus.
>> Did were you Did you hear about what happened with Lord
Rush? >> No. What What happened? >> Uh so he's been
he pulled on Nani essentially and used my name and uh Beckett's
names and other people's names to essentially like uh like strongarm
>> Mhm. That's annoying.
um and was creepy to somebody like straight the
>> Okay,
I've not been calling this guy a snake behind the scenes. And
also, you know that but that is like what other people say. And
also, did you hear about all this other really crazy that happened
with him? >> I mean, are you not the one being a snake
behind the scenes here? I don't talk about this guy, but here's
a whole bunch of that people say
>> and the reason this person never came to us cuz she
said, and I quote, I I feel uncomfortable with uh with Killjoy
and Ash in the room uh specifically Ash because of Emra and I
really don't want myself to be content.
Um, and that and that kind of I took that to heart. It was like,
listen, these people aren't necess and this was like a newer
mod. Like, these people aren't feeling comfortable because of
XYZ. I can tell them I trust these people, but if they don't
implicitly trust them, I need to kind of make some things very
clear.
>> but so then it sounds like you were like, "Okay, let
me go and accommodate the new mods over Ash and KJ."
>> No, not necessarily. This has been on the table for
a while. This this restructuring has been on the table for uh
over a month. >> So, you had been thinking about >> moving.
Okay. >> Yeah. This restructuring has been there for over
a month because a uh Ash is fine. Um Ash has done the thumbnail
>> Um but like a specific thing was asked uh yesterday.
Uh can I rejoin while working for Malcolm? I said no. I don't
like Malcolm. I'm sorry. I I I have to draw a line. It's not
a purity test >> Now, wait. Do we have any DMs like that?
cuz that's not what we've been seeing everywhere else is like
him making up this thing. I don't feel like she asked, "Can I
rejoin?" Cuz after the mod call, she didn't say, "Can I can I
rejoin
while I work for Malcolm?" She said, "Can I join streams?" And
this guy goes, "Do you still work for Malcolm?" That's what I
heard. It was not It was not her saying, "Well, as long as I
still work for this >> FD Mongoose guy, can I can I rejoin
streams?" Or, "Can I join the stream?" >> Yeah. No, his
his explanation here is totally incoherent with uh with the rest
with the last we had. >> This guy's a logging me and I
I just don't feel comfortable with it anymore. >> So So
you don't So by join you mean join the ops? like like come back
on cuz Ash didn't uh Ash has taken time off the
>> because out of out of
it was something that we agreed upon and I said like if you're
still working for Malcolm >> Was it agreed upon or was
he like oh did he tell her this? >> I think you should
take some time off. I think you should not be on the stream.
>> He's going to put you in a line of fire. Malcolm from
my understanding doesn't even credit uh them on their thumbnails.
>> Okay. So, how are is she going to end up in the line
of fire? There's no credit even be g being given. >> Does
anybody even know that she's working on the thumbnails? >> And
what's going to happen?
>> Want that for them? >> You shouldn't come on the
stream while you're working with this guy, even though he doesn't
credit you. Because I'm worried people will put you in the crosshairs
because you work for this guy. And I'm worried about you. That's
why I think you shouldn't come on the stream anymore.
Just a lot of
it's a lot of man. I mean, they really they really shouldn't
get I I I don't think they should get credited for most of the
work as long as they're getting paid. I think it's fine to not
get credited, >> but
if uh if Ash wants to get on like
stream and if Ash is bagged,
I mean, that's that's on them, right? I don't >> I I mean,
I know you don't with Malcolm, but like it it doesn't really
sound like it's over the work. It sounds more like you don't
with Malcolm, so you don't want Ash on it. No, that's not what
I'm saying. I miss I misspoke when I said it. I'll reiterate
what I was saying cuz I realized I was speaking too fast. >> You
misspoke speaking too fast.
>> How about I slow it down for you, Diesel? How to slow
it down for you? >> I've seen FPS Diesel. He looks like
he's possibly half black, right? Maybe maybe Fali should slow
it down for him, right? >> Yeah, I think so.
That's what you don't listen too good. Slow it down, Falgi. >> I
would never personally say that, by the way. That's just clearly
what Falgi is imp implying right here. Okay. That's what I'm
hearing.
>> He's saying is is that I made it very clear to Malcolm
that I didn't want my friend to be [__] over. I also
made this clear to Beck spoke with him today. Yeah. And I made
this clear to Becket when I spoke with him today. I said >> uh
because the the ask was why was KJ why is KJ being called like
an op? And I said I never said that. I never said >> I
just never have. Um,
and
um,
like I I've never done that. What I explained to what I explained
to them, and this is this was me speaking out of turn, is I don't
want retaliation towards you from him while you're on my >> Yeah.
But that's that's ultimately like >> that's that's their
choice. But I I I I couldn't live with my conscience over
The lie's falling apart.
FPS Diesel's applying a little bit of pressure to it and he's
like immediately saying something absurd.
>> that's her call to make. I couldn't live with myself.
Something bad happened to
>> It's in the drama, bro.
>> Are you crazy? >> Are you kidding me?
>> No, I'm not. Like, no, I'm not kidding you, dude. Like,
I I I don't want to screw other people's bags over it. I didn't
kick K. But then that's Ash's bag to screw over. Like
>> so you kicked her out. If I didn't kick KJ out.
>> So Killjoy's just been kicked out. Hold >> He's
over it. >> I didn't kick KJ. >> Yeah, but then that's
Ash. >> Oh, sorry. I didn't kick KJ out. Sorry. I I misheard.
I >> like I I don't want to screw other people's bags over
it. I didn't kick KJ. >> Yeah, but then that's Ash's bag
to screw over. Like if Ash >> it doesn't it doesn't to
me it doesn't sound like a good reason to be like you shouldn't
be on stream. Like if you don't want Ash on stream just be like
I don't think you should be on stream. And yeah Ash is an editor.
Ash should focus on those things. >> Yes. You know >> they
never lost their editing role ever. That and that was something
that was expressed. I understand what you're saying. That's just
my internal that's just my internal logic. You may not agree
with it. You may think I'm like childish in that logic but it
is my >> I I do I do think it's childish actually. Um,
yeah, I I think I do think that
and part of this comes down to I remember a conversation in opt
talk where Ash was getting heat for taking clients who like don't
like you.
Um, and honestly, like
if you're a contractor and you do contract work, like if if Cat
got money to draw a picture of me that was unflattering, I would
not care. And there is this
there was this preconceived notion that you do not go after people's
like contractors like that.
>> Um and obviously that has changed.
>> You are. >> But I'm not doing that. If you think
that I'm doing that, I'm going to veittly push back on that because
I was the one that gave Ash the okay. >> I hate Yeah.
>> people that try and use big words. Well, if you don't
know the word vehemently, if you don't know the whatever word
he was trying to say in DMs to that about me, if you don't know
what was the one he misused on Twitter, he said slide boy has
conducted his himself with a high degree of efficacy.
I think he meant like he's highly ethical,
but he said he's conducted himself with a high degree of efficacy.
>> What are you saying, man?
>> Don't use the words. If you're going to >> I don't
think Wait, he didn't misuse vehemently there.
It was fine. >> Well, it sort of it was a bit awkward.
It was a bit awkward the way he used it. I think >> sounded
awkward, but yeah,
>> it was an awkward use of the word. And he's constantly
doing it. Either awkwardly using things or misusing things. Stop
talking like that. Don't know how the words are used. Just use
words that you understand. Use words that you can actually string
together. >> Yeah. No, I totally agree.
I'm I'm a big believer in I I'll use a word that I think I know
and that I'll realize I don't totally know it and I'll like break
it down into different words like in the moment because I it
actually drives me insane when other people do it. Use big words
that are just totally misused.
Total total fear of being anything close to aerodite to be honest
with you.
Just getting anywhere near that is immediately like ah terrifying
to me. But I know there was I know there was
>> frustrations with it. I know Cloudy vocalized it too.
So I'm sure it came up between the
wrong too. He was saying I'm trying to keep you a breast.
>> He wasn't finishing it and saying keep you a breast
of the situation. That's that would be the phrase generally.
Keep you a breast of the situation. Like keep you on top of the
situation. That's sort of like what a breast is saying. Uh just
to say I'm trying to keep you a breast. That's not how anyone
uses that. It's not what anyone that's not how anyone says that
ever. >> I mean,
off the top, I'll be real with you. Off the top of my head, I
feel like people do say keep your breast, but I it doesn't matter
to me. It's like not really super relevant. >> I've never
heard someone say specifically like that. I've always I've always
heard keep your breast situation.
>> Yeah, I didn't when I heard that I did not hear anything
weird there for me, but it's Yeah, it's fine. I It just sounded
It sounded weird. Like people don't use that word, but it didn't
sound like he was using it. It
I even if he's using it correctly, he's using like weird um he's
using like Yeah. non-standard language in places just for like
no reason. It's not helping, right? Like it it's only >> it
seems like deliberate to change his perception. That's the thing,
right? >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Issues with
the three of them. No, Queen Bee. No, I'm not going to sit here
and snark on this guy when I don't agree. That would be gay if
I disagreed with what Quan was saying and I'm just like, eh,
whatever. I should say so. Obviously, >> that I don't have
or let me rephrase that. I accepted. >> Um,
truth be told, she was told the reason why Q made a separate
server. Uh, there was an allegation that I would be the next
Tyler that they would be waiting to get off of. >> Mhm.
Yeah. >> I wasn't there for the conversation. I wasn't
there for the conversation and I
>> Do we know who Q is? Q is another member of like the
ops or whatever the research team but do we know that guy has
not been mentioned at all or what? Like I've heard it I've heard
the name mentioned but is he just different guy here? You damn
queen walked away. We're >> Didn't care. >> Um my
friendship and my loyalty to them came first. >> I see.
>> Got it. It just doesn't feel as if that's being reciprocated
in the similar way because
I gave an open form yesterday to have the discussion. If people
felt uncomfortable, if they thought I was doing something wrong,
I would have appreciated it and I kept asking I kept asking like,
"Hey, do you guys have any issues with this? Do you want to discuss
this? Hey, do you have any issues with this? Do you want to discuss
this?"
>> And like nothing happens. And it's I am trying to my
personal thing is I am trying to be a better friend
not a boss. And I realize that my frustrations are bosslike.
They are not friendlike. And it feels like
the de
>> Yo, how's it going? >> I'm all right. How are
you?
>> Good. You should switch your
should
be
sona.
Why isn't it why isn't your thing in what is it?
Why isn't your thing in reactive setup to be a morona? >> I
can hold on
>> delineation between the two or the grace that I give
other people is not being thrown back at me. >> I I know
when you like do quote unquote bosslike work, you have a tendency
to beat around a bush instead of just
straight up say it. Like I don't I from what I heard and was
told it was like you opened a floor. Q asked what he could do
to help and you were like nope there's nothing. >> Uh yeah
that happened. Is there something more I could do to help you?
No, no, no. We don't need your help anymore. We're looking forward
to what you produce on your own channel. >> He asked regarding
mod stuff. >> He just in general. >> Okay. Well,
if that's if that's the qu if that's how I interpreted it. So
that's on me. But honestly speaking, there hasn't been anything
for Q to do for a very long time.
>> But I did >> Can we just call it like it is? He's
not good on stream and you would prefer he not be on stream cuz
his audio QUALITY IS BAD? >> UH, NO. It wasn't the audio
quality stuff. Uh, it was inconsistencies. He would inconsistently
be on stream. He would not be on stream, things like >> Okay.
So then that's the reason you don't want him on stream.
>> But I I didn't kick Q off stream. I want to make that
very >> Yeah, I know you didn't kick, but you showed the
door.
>> Sure, you could say that. Yeah, but then like why didn't
you vocalize?
>> I ran a stream like this and I ran into like
like 0.1%
of this gay drama.
How How did these people get into all of the gay management drama
between themselves while running the stream? I I don't get it.
You could avoid all of this. Oh, did you set it up? Oh, you didn't
set it up yet. Sorry. Somebody said, "We love moral sonas, but
I didn't see it." >> Why didn't you just tell them like,
"Bro, I don't think that you work on stream is what I'm saying.
H if I if I'm being honest, um I if I'm being honest, I was trying
to preserve his feelings, as stupid as that may >> Yeah,
I I can tell you it was infinitely the wrong way to go about
it. 100% should have just ripped the band-aid
>> Okay. And that's fine. And I and I can accept that.
I can absolutely accept that it was the incorrect way to go about
it. I can absolutely accept that. I don't like cutting off friends.
I don't like telling friends. Um
I don't like telling friends something like that's hurtful. Um
especially Q. Um just because he always does blame himself. It
was the Tyler stuff and the Mari stuff that other and I don't
I never wanted that. Um
I didn't want that for him specifically. Uh when it came to KJ
and Ash,
their programs were running the same way they were always running.
>> Mhm. Um, Ash was still going to do editing.
Um, Ash was still going to help me with thumbnails. I started
editing myself. The only reason I wanted to do that is so I can
take a little bit of load off of everybody. Um, because I know
that Greg started a new job and won't be around. >> And
Ash is busy with other people's responsibilities and I wanted
to learn from myself. >> Yeah. And that happened like right
after the quote unquote meeting, right? >> Uh, yes. It
was it wasn't supposed to be time that way. >> That was
a horrible decision. I don't know what the you were thinking,
but that made you look like a humongous
>> Okay. I mean, I'm going to be an You want me to be honest?
I'm going to be an either way. I'm sorry, but that's just >> Yeah,
I I I get it, but it >> nice. Got a morona. Let's go. He's
going to be an either way. >> And right after whenever
Diesel starts pushing him, you know, he sounds so angry that
he's not like falling for it. >> Yeah. It's like very transparent
what he's doing. It's very funny >> that that's what I
kept saying when I was listening to it because it's like
it is like insulting to I think everyone like in the mod call
Diesel here just everyone that
uh he thought that this would work like
it's so it's like parody like what a what a parody video would
treat like a manipulator right >> like if he if he wanted
to do this the easy way to do this with nobody getting
He just starts his own Foggy channel, right? And he just streams
on that >> and then he doesn't do the OP block stream.
He switches over. He doesn't use the Discord. Doesn't take any
of the shared assets. He just starts his own thing and he goes
and he says, "Okay, I can't spend any more time on this. I'm
going to start my own thing and go and do my own thing." >> The
the issue is the uh Oh, do you mean like as a response to this?
No, before any of this, if he wants to do his own solo streams,
which is like clearly what he's indicating is I don't >> You
should have just used the existing platform to show his solo
thing and then just transitioned over. That's literally how how
you would do it. >> Yeah, exactly. And like >> people
all the people that are there for OP were there for Fei anyway
to be honest. Like FGI did draw a lot of the viewers by,
you know, being like the main streamer, right? They're going
to most of the viewers are going to go where the main streamer
is. So, he's going to >> he would take whatever, you know,
80 viewers they had. >> I mean, I I think it's the the
whole like hostile takeover thing that he did. Um, but like ultimately,
yeah, he is the Oblock. Like, people aren't watching for like
the random co-host that he has. People are watching for him.
So, it makes sense that he kicked those other people off. I think
it's a thing to do because it was started as a group channel
and the way he did it was like super There's probably a way he
could have gone about it where it wouldn't have been. I bet you
if he just said, >> I'm focusing on this channel a lot.
I'm the primary streamer on the channel. I'd like to take it
over and make it my own thing.
Um, could I pay you guys out? Could I do something to make this
work?" I understand money was like tight for him to begin with,
but it's like, could I make this work for you guys somehow so
that I could take this over and make it like more a thing I want
to do?
Because otherwise, I think I might be going off on my own. I'm
sure if he if he'd approached it that way, it's like there's
a certain thing he's I feel like for people when they're basically
being gaslit like super hard, they are going to have a hard time
like agreeing and going along with it. You know what I
>> And that seems like what's happening here is he's just
he's telling these people like this is how it is and they can
all see that's not >> he's like played along like this
is this is just for fun. This is just us friends doing something
for like way too long as well. It's like you need to be clear
with people like I' I've got ambitions for this. I want to make
this my streaming career, you know?
basically played along for way too long when that was never what
you wanted. >> Yeah, I I'm not picking up as much of that.
I could see it when you point it out. I could see it, but I'm
probably not as deep in this yet to be able to see like all of
the cases. >> But I can agree that when you point out like,
oh, he wants to talk about drama in the group chat. I I can see
that when you point it out. I think I haven't seen enough of
his interactions yet, but now it's becoming more clear when he's
getting pushed back and he's like getting upset about it >> that
now it's becoming more clear what he wants from this. >> The
quote unquote meeting, right? >> Yes. It was supposed to
be that way. >> That was a horrible decision. I don't know
what the you were thinking, but that made you look like a humongous.
>> Okay. I mean, I'm going to be an You want me to be honest?
I'm going to be an either way. I'm sorry, but that's >> Yeah,
I I get it, but it was like, you know, it's like a time and place.
It's like you're like, I want to preserve the friendship. I want
to be nice to these people, but then also in the same breath,
hey, teach me uh teach me the thing that's going to make you
obsolete. Also, I don't want you on stream because your association
with Malcolm. It's >> oh yeah,
you would have seen that part right at the end of the mod call.
Basically, after he's done firing everyone and they're all said
and done, he says, "Uh, so can you guys help teach me to edit?
>> I still want to be friends." Yeah. Very cool. Very,
very cool. I bet you these people are enough that one of one
or two of them might have said like, "Yeah, maybe." They did
help like a funny thing. So, we learned this on Dickers today.
Um, the girl who helped him learn how to edit, uh, she ditched
a plan that she had with her at the time fiance uh, to help him
learn how to edit. >> So, they're not fiance anymore.
>> Not fiance anymore. They had a falling out. I'm not
sure >> what happened there, but
>> can't imagine why. >> Do you do you actually know
what happened there or sorry, you actually know what happened?
I I I knew she was uh engaged at the time. Um like when I spoke
to her, she she was known as the girl with like a
>> Well, just I'm hearing that you're in everyone's DMs
here. Is this true? >> I was in her DMs cuz she co-hosted
like two streams or something similar, but no, I did not try
to this girl. She was and engaged
when married or whatever.
>> So, so he swears not in her DMs.
>> Okay. All right. Fair enough. >> I understand
that. I understand that it was poorly timed. I I'm Am I disagreeing
with you?
>> I'm not disagreeing with you, dude. It's just like at
at this point, I have given and given and given a lot >> and
it feels like I did not get the same courtesy in return. >> No
one has talked to me. I reached out the moment I found out that
this whole Becket KJ thing was going on, I reached out to Becket.
I did all this behind the scenes work because I'm like trying
to figure out what the >> what's the Becket KJ thing, bro?
Is that just KJ telling
>> really upset that >> KJ has been smeared so he
>> KJ thing basically there's this mod/ress researcher
named Killjoy
and he
>> he was slandered by
>> Oh, okay. Yeah, he's been slandered by um
uh Fali and Cloudy as a doxer uh as someone who repackages research
from other people and then sells it himself. Stuff like that,
which caused everybody uh basically in or around Beckett space
to think that this guy's like a docer, like a weird uh Alog freak
guy. Um
so he these people basically and they did this to Ash as well.
I'm not sure to what severity because what they said about Ash
hasn't been made public, but Becca I think alluded to it on his
stream. So these people basically fired um the uh original creators
of the channel and then tried to like blackball them completely,
lie about them so that way nobody would like ever talk to them
again or have them around in their
Um yeah, obviously terrible. Why?
I wonder why if there's some deeper like riff there if that's
what's causing this like what this guy would have done to FG
at some point that he'd want to do that.
Are you So you're calling it slander so it's just not true. There's
no like it's like basically baseless. >> There is as far
as I have been shown and as far as anybody who has been told
these things uh nobody has seen any evidence. Uh Fali was basically
Fei and Cloudy. Fali was going under like I am Faly of the Oblak.
I do good research. Everybody was taking him at his word. Uh,
and then Cloudy was um I am Cloudy, wife of the OP block. Uh,
take me at my word. So, everybody just trusted them because of
their reputation as like good
>> Oh, okay. Very strange.
Very, very strange. >> Who was pushing the idea? Who was
pushing the idea they were good researchers? You say, >> uh,
I think Fali himself and then Diesel
>> Who else? >> I don't know. I I >> He just
said
>> who else?
>> Sure. Be back probably. >> I would assume. I don't
know. >> That's a good one. But like who else? >> Oh,
it's Dick.
>> Oh, I Okay. I don't know. I don't watch a lot of Dicker's
content. Um, so I feel like I've missed
>> About block or about Falgy or about
>> About Fi. He's good. It's good research. >> Yeah.
So, he's just kind of the thing is he didn't do any of the research.
I mean, the big drama with Killjoy is he lost his research when
they removed his uh mod roll world cuz he stored all of it in
their Discord server. So, like these people did not do any research.
They just kind of got people who did and then obviously they
worked under the channel. Um, so it's like Mr. Beast like
what's a good example of this? It's like saying Hassan did all
the charity work in Cuba when like it's really the charity organization
that did maybe. Is that sure? >> Yeah. Does that kind of
add up what I'm trying to get at? >> Oh, I can just see
>> I went with Sorry. When Dickers Yeah, I can already
see. I'm trying to think of why Dickers would say this is the
reason Dickers would think this because Fouchy would give him
like a bunch of stuff from this channel that a bunch of other
people had researched. is that
I because to me when I hear somebody's like this guy's really
good at research. To me that means this guy's giving me links
for my stream and out of context and he was helpful. I'm gonna
say he's a really good researcher. That's what it sounds like
to me. >> I don't even know what said that to be honest.
I know Dicker swept this guy so I'm Dickers.
>> Oh um I don't know. I can't speak to exactly what Dickers
has said. I don't know. But I would say if he was like a block
is a good researcher whatever. I would assume it's just based
on the fact that like people kind of just like said that um without
really >> is that type of guy, isn't he? I agree.
>> Yeah, but people just kind of said it and then didn't
really like >> Now I need to actually see what No, now
I need to actually see what Dicker said cuz Queen's just making
things up and he's openly admitting it. So
>> go ahead. Go ahead and show me what Dicker said. I I
don't even want to have further discussion on it cuz this guy
just made some [__] Uh, how does Fouchi's name appear
in YouTube transcripts? Film Dick's channel for Fei. Find all
the time spoken by him.
>> Uh-huh. Okay. Well, somebody could do that. I'm going
to hit play on this. I'm getting some water. Just give me a >> The
[__] is going on here? This is inappropriate. This
is not what KJ did. >> You just asked Queen B to do it.
Is that what you're doing right now? >> Okay. Well,
>> yeah. Uh, and it feels like if
if an issue was made
to me regarding that, regardless of how I handled it, if it was
in the inopportune fashion or the incorrect fashion,
I show grace that I don't receive in return. And it's not the
first time that >> it's like what if they're not what would
you like this meeting happens like what is what is the grace
you're expecting or >> if there was if there were private
concerns I would have appreciated them to just come to me privately
and we would have spoken about it privately. >> Yeah. I
don't I don't really know or think if there were private concerns
from their end cuz I >> I mean the conversation happened
privately. I What does he want?
I don't I don't know if he has any right to that, especially
when it's like a group channel and he changes all the permissions
and a bunch of people get told they can't come on anymore.
>> I don't know. It seems kind of odd to >> Ask them
about it and >> of course they're going to go to the guy
and they all get their clout from Diesel, right? >> Like
Diesel's the big YouTuber that they're all extended off of. >> So
like he's mad that people have gone and said this guy's a total
our little group thing. Heed it up and now Diesel's kind of dressing
him down and he's acting like he's totally betrayed over it.
It sounds like other people were having discussions about this
beforehand
So like he's just he's just that Diesel's upset with him now
that Diesel's pointing out that >> I believe
if I'm remembering correctly, Becca said that Diesel had already
watched the recording that you watched earlier before this. Um,
so they watch it together later on, but I'm under the impression,
if I'm remembering correctly, that um
this guy just like knew that Dickers
not Dickers that Fi was uh was lying to him like to his face.
Um >> Yeah. Well, he called him out already on this. He's
like, "That's not what was said in the thing." >> Like
the he said the Q guy asked what he could help with. >> And
Fali goes, "Well, no, he asked about helping with modding." He's
like, "No." He asked about any kind of help in
>> Very funny. >> And it's like, >> so yeah,
he he has one. >> We're like, "Oh, yeah, we do stuff."
It's like, um, I know the amount of D and D being played was
like a an issue or whatever,
>> but like >> Mhm. I mean, it's
they sit in this VC for 16 hours and then like I like, you know
what I mean? Like I'm going to be kind of blunt. Like it was
very So this is my issue. It's purely my issue. >> These
people spend a ton of time in Discord and they're total losers.
That's my issue.
Uh-huh. It's
I maybe I'm misunderstanding. Is that not this guy's thing, too?
They all spend a ton of time in Discord. That's basically the
whole ACC, isn't it?
>> Fali is no better than any of these people. He's just
trying to act like it doesn't stink. It's like really bizarre.
I don't really understand
>> why. Strange, man. >> Not so much Ash,
but
it would have been really nice if somebody said, "Hey, um,
uh, D and D is my main focus now."
>> I didn't get that. I have like I'm pulling teeth.
>> I hear during the the meeting that you didn't really
like put that on the table. You kind of were like beating around
just saying. >> I have the meeting recorded if you want
to hear it. I don't really like I I I if I'm beating around,
I'm beating around. I will I will show it. I'm not gonna I'm
not [__] around anymore. Like
>> like I I'm I'm kind of at a point where I'm a little
frustrated because it's like I I it feels like for the fourth
time this year, my friendship is being taken advantage of
for the fourth time. First it was Tyler, then it was Mari. Uh
not so much the the the size the size me off, but it's whatever.
And now it's
it's by the people like closest to me that I would defend time
and time again.
Um, what I I I actually the Westside Tyler getting [__]
over. >> Yeah, I'm just saying what does he think he's
getting over on? He just took everybody's perms away. He basically
cut out all all the other the group >> and he's like I've
been betrayed for the last time. For the fourth time in the last
time. >> I don't even person on Dicker's stream
>> Yeah. Yeah, I agree. Um, that Mari person went on Dicker's
stream and she basically did like a paragraph to Fali because
to TLDDR what she said on his stream cuz she talks about having
like a brain tumor and it's like kind of
um she
she's like
Fali uh would have us do a bunch of research for things for the
OP block. So we were doing a bunch of research for things for
the op. Then uh when he would come to stream he would stream
about like just what every other commentary channel was talking
about. our research would go to nowhere and then we all like
just nothing was being done with our research. So I basically
went to him and I was like, "Hey, like what are we doing? Um
like I don't understand
what the goal is here. You're having us do all of this work that's
never getting used." Um
and stuff like that. Uh and this resulted in Merkari being kicked
because Fali was like upset or whatever. Uh, so what I sent you
is his response to that like big thing and he's like, I feel
so hurt right now. It's just very like
>> Do you have a non like two pixel image of this? >> This
is the image. >> I have Dicker's time stamp where he shows
it on stream, but no, it's a very blurry screenshot.
>> I'm going to be reinviting people in the server. I'm
incredibly upset with the actions that have taken place because
I did not want this at all. I'm so incredibly hurt. This is FG.
Wow. I'm so
>> This was a private friend server for things like playing
games together and stuff. And someone was leaking the server
to Kiwi Farms. Um
to this day, nobody really knows who, but the person who was
leaking on to Kiwi Farms was apparently using things like Partard
and stuff like that. Um, which is why people were like, I don't
know who this would be because all of these people are like incredibly
like woke uh, and like soy. So, like none of them would probably
use those words, I guess. Um,
but
Merkari was eventually blamed for it like blindly with no reason.
Uh, and they were kicked uh, from the server. Um, which caused
like some infighting and then I think some people left because
of that. Um, so that's like the other big drama before this.
uh before people like these people were kicked. Merkari got kicked
and then a bunch of people kind of left due to that and then
uh this is the most recent kicking with like Ash and all those
people uh which basically left the server to or not the server
the channel to just FG.
>> Okay. All right. Good context. >> Like when people
did people told me I probably shouldn't have done that
and
I can admit that I didn't handle everything correctly. I'm okay
with that. But it just feels like it just feels like it never
mattered. >> Yeah. I uh I mean I'm I'm willing to sit down
and listen to the meeting. Um aside from that uh Yeah. I mean
I know they're in like a VC for a lot of the day, but it's like
one of those things where it's like even if they're playing D
and D like and and it's happened for me too, right? Where I'm
like, "Okay, I'm busy. All right, D and D's canceled. Okay, go
do the thing that you need to do. Go do the work you need to
do." >> So, but like those things need to be
>> just said to them, right? I know you're kind of like
putting them in a position. It's like, oh, are you going to do
this or D and D? But like they're going to do that if you like
bring it up,
but it doesn't seem like you brought it up. >> Uh the D
and D stuff
or specifically >> Well, I'm saying that, but you know,
like, oh, you know, they're in a VC 16 hours a day, right? >> I
I mean, well, well, now it's my frustration. I I didn't bring
that up because I don't personally care what they do on their
off time. >> Mhm. Yeah. But you're looking at what they're
doing in off time and being like, "Oh, well, maybe they could
do something for the channel in that off time."
At least that's how it reads when you're telling me it.
>> Yeah, that is how it reads. It's probably out of turn.
I think my I think my personal I think it's I feel a little raw.
I'm not going to lie. Um I feel a little frustrated.
I feel incredibly hurt because I I've known how they've talked
about me behind my back for a period of time and I let it go.
>> Well, I know there was the thing about like KJ was venting
one time in a public BC, right? Is that what we're referring
to in the >> That's not just that. I know about the T.
I know about the Tyler comment. That wasn't a public.
>> Okay. I I knew he had beef with this guy from somewhere
else. That that would be why, you know, any smears would be
>> Yeah, probably there's some reason that he would talk
about him here.
>> Wait, I can't. Did somebody just That's not just that.
I know about the I know about the Tyler comment that wasn't a
private. Yes, >> I I know the reason why the other server
was made.
yes, he openly told Cloudy that the reason he made it is because
he found me
>> Yeah. I mean, I don't know. I Q seemed to have really
liked you, so I don't know about that
uh personally, but I mean, you're hearing it from your partner,
so I'm not and I and I of course don't know, so obviously I'm
not >> you know, saying, "Oh, don't believe them, right?"
Um, >> and and and I want to make it clear that it's just
like I I put all those things to the side. >> But yeah,
to to circle back on the Tyler thing, I know Claudia came to
me about the Tyler comment that I believe it was Ash who made
that one, right? >> Uh, I don't know who made it cuz >> Okay.
Well, there you go. It was Ash. Um, cuz Claudia told me. Um.
>> Okay. Tell me who made it. >> Yeah. And it was
more like,
and okay, I'm I'm sure you get it now because like this has happened
multiple times. I've experienced this multiple times. It happened
with the Reddit crew when I was
It happened with Core. It's happened before. Like I it obviously
has happened, right? I've experienced it. Of course, when that
happens, if you're close enough to the person, there's like this,
you know, apprehensive fear. Oh, I have a friend. They're kind
of in the same position as this other friend. I hope it doesn't
all fall apart, right? I I get that frustration of fear. I don't
think it's something said out of like malicious discontent with
your attitude and more like a like I don't want to live that
experience again cuz it was, you know, harrowing, right? And
I'm sure by now you understand what that is because of all the
drama, right? And every and I had asked about this and I had
talked to the people about this and I had relayed that to Cloudy
where I'm like, well, you know, what said was said can't be unsaid.
You just have to kind of like prove it wrong, right? If you value
the person, then you're going to go out of your way to do it.
Cloudy didn't really seem to be interested in that. I'm like,
that's fine, whatever. Um, but like, you know, I I get where
the person would be coming from in that case. I'm not excusing
that it wasn't a mean thing to say because you also experienced
Tyler, but I understand it because I lived it, right? And this
is just the worst conversation. I'm
I This is wild. This like I just can't I can't handle
like why are you concerned about somebody's motivation? Why is
this? >> No. Well, maybe. But what what's coming? Where
are we going after this? Oh, well, >> thank you. And even
now I'm sitting here going, "Okay, well, here we go. I don't
want this to be another core thing, >> right? So I I get
it. >> You want You think I'm going to be >> No,
not you. I I don't know who, right? Or even the only reason that
this is even related to that is like the like I know that they
play a lot of D and D and that sometimes overlaps with like stream
or responsibilities and I know that was an issue for him with
me. Uh and it was one of the things he got frustrated with me
at. I mean, listen, I don't again I want to make it like very
expressly perfectly clear. I have no issues with Hal. I want
to make that very clear. If Hal came to me and talked to me about
it, I would say the same thing. We'd probably have disagreements,
but I'd probably say the same thing that I don't have any ill
will towards her. >> Yeah. I I figured it's not about Hal,
but more or less the act of like
uh playing a game over like
>> I think my issue is personally speaking,
I think I think my my personal issue is that and I'll accept
responsibility. I think no one was honest about their
>> Um I mean, I'll be perfectly honest with you. Uh KJ
just messaged me uh pulling out his DM as well as saying he doesn't
want to do research anymore. um that he and his wife spoke and
she doesn't like what she hears about the research side. >> So
I I don't know how true that is, but I will I will say that whatever
his wife says matters and that's pretty much it. Um that that's
conscientious decision, they are both grown adults in a relationship
and they say precedence over anything I have to do. M
>> um but like if I hear that that's not the case and if
I hear that that's not what's happening and I hear KJ's assisting
somebody, I mean like that's going to be [__] up
to me >> because like I mean okay you should like if you
if he had a direct confrontation with a killjoy person was like
I think you just don't really like me and I think that's why
you're actually saying this and I just appreciate if you'd say
it directly and then KJ was like no no no no I have no problem
with you then I could maybe agree with him but like I think that's
the assumption you make and you just move forward with that.
If if KJ's not, you know, if KJ was just being somewhat professional,
what would be in the regular word called professional, I don't
think you'd really be that upset about that. Would you want him
to say like, "Actually, you in particular, I hate you." That's
kind of weird. I wouldn't expect that. >> Like
I I'm taking people at the word. >> Yeah. Well, I mean,
it it to me I don't It sounds like he just doesn't want to work
with you, but I I don't know what his like
>> what he's planning for himself. I know he wants to do
like Dn D stuff >> more creatively. So, it's like okay,
maybe that's what he does. But that I haven't spoken to him about.
>> Um I he did tell me that he was like there's like an
OP section in like the OP block server that had like research
stuff in it. He was removed from it. >> There's no research
in that at all. The fighting stuff. There's no research in there.
Not to my knowledge. >> Was he was he removed from it?
>> Uh that would be Cloudy. I don't know. >> Oh,
that's weird. That's very weird that cuz I'm being told that
he stored all of his research in there. So, wouldn't that have
Yep. >> Do you think it's something like did they delete
all of his messages or something and that included his research?
That would be kind of
>> No. No. He did store his research there and Fali did
know about it because he's literally the research guy who was
using all of these people for research. Uh so what he's doing
is basically he knows that he got that taken away from him cuz
he doesn't like Killjoy. He's trying to with Killjoy. Uh so he's
trying to do the uh you know the whole koi like oh I didn't know
that. like, "No, you you're dead. You obviously dead cuz you're
>> um I think that she I think she may have had a discussion
with him about it." >> Um but literally all there's there
is Scarlet Reaper. >> Yeah. I'll need I'll need to circle
back with him again, but he was telling me that there was >> Yeah,
it's called findings >> stuff lost access to and he was
>> Yeah, he lost access to certain things. He lost access
to the findings tab was more uh moderator stuff as well. It wasn't
just research stuff. There's mod stuff in that as well. >> Okay.
Well, >> because Scarlet privately is mod stuff. Well,
then that stuff also needs to be like, you know, two is one and
one is none, right? So, it's like if you can move from that,
well, then he lost access to something that could be useful in
the future. And it's like, okay, well, you need to make sure
that that's like accessible to somebody who does something like
that. >> Yeah. And I and I did express that I did want
mod access that access back to him to Cloudy. So, I'd have to
circle back and ask her what their ultimate conversation was
about it cuz I know they had a conversation about it. >> I
didn't reach a reach a amicable end anyway. So, if I'm just hazing,
>> I don't I don't think so either. I mean, I can tell
you right now she's very hurt by them. Uh
>> um she feels very betrayed because uh for a long time
she felt like >> I feel like uh I feel like his wife or
his partner here, the cloudy person, is very used to him invoking
her and then her she just comes in and is like, "Yeah, whatever
he said, that's the case." Cuz I feel like I've watched this
guy invoke like other people to defend or like advocate for what
he wants. He keeps invoking other people. I would I suspect it's
something like this with the with the cloudy person as well.
Like maybe they agree, but I don't think that's even something
that enters his head. I think he just knows that she's the person
that he could say like has this opinion and she'll just go along
with it no matter what. That's how I feel about this. I'm like
I'm seeing who this guy is. I [__] I hate this so
much. Um I need you to do this thing for me, but it's actually
for you. It me off so much when people do this. >> She
didn't have a space in her own server. Um but just because of
everything that happened with Bari. >> Um and found out
more on her own without me present and wanted to spare my feelings
for a period of time.
I have to message people now cuz with this drop I have to now
pay things that I have to pay out. Um I mean there's there's
other stuff behind the scenes that I'm not very happy about.
Um that I don't think I ever approached um that I don't think
is important. Uh no it's not it's not important
because it's it's I think it's just I don't want to vent to you
about our friends or I guess my ex-friend. Well, I mean I the
issue is that I kind of get stuck in the middle of these things
as I have to like a mediator or investigator every time. >> Um
which I'm fine doing. I just don't want to be the one that's
actively going out and like the only reason I found out about
this is because like I heard like I like like literally I joined
a VC and like the vibes were weird. I'm like something going
on >> and so like so everyone's talking about it. That's
nice. I would have appreciated being told. >> I had asked
right because I >> but if I'm being but if I'm being perfectly
honest it's not for Cat Hal costic and other people to know about.
>> That's what my staffing are. Are you surprised that
your friends are talking to their friends about a thing they're
frustrated with? >> Sure. But here's my issue is is that
I gave them open space to talk to me about >> I mean, I
give them >> then we might as well just watch this >> Like
I Yeah, I don't care anymore. Like I'm I go I'm trying to put
my personal feelings to the side. I am actually trying to because
I I'm actually really upset now because it feels like no matter
what I did, no matter what I do, I'm always the bad
>> And it's like
I did things because I cared about people and I thought they
cared about me the same way. >> Yeah. I mean, out of talking
to them, they all seem just as hurt as you. So, it's like I don't
think anybody I listen, I'm assuming no
malicious >> No. No. No.
Really? No. I I'm sorry. I need a minute. >> This is like
the most dangerous kind of like psycho. Okay. The kind that like
really believes it. The kind that can like like he basically
has convinced himself of all of these fictions. Like actually,
you know what I'm saying? >> Like he is the worst kind
of psycho in this situation. He is. He really believes he's the
victim. He does not think that he's like not a victim. He thinks
he's totally a victim here when he's not. It's psychotic.
Go ahead. >> The best part is um this isn't the full call.
In the full call after this, his voice just goes straight back
to normal. It's so funny.
>> Oh, is there another call?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Do you want to >> Yeah, maybe. Is
Quimman still here? Is Quumman What do you think, Quan? We watch
this other call where he's like totally fine again. Queen fall
asleep. Queen is in a marathon game almost certainly, right?
>> Hold on.
>> You got it linked. All right. You're you you got it.
You can guide.
>> So, it's just the same call. So, just go to the time
stamp where you left off. So, like 30 minutesish. >> Yeah.
I mean, out of talking to them, they all seem just as hurt as
you. So it's like
I don't think anybody I listen I'm assuming no
malicious intent.
right here. I need a minute.
Oh, he took the minute. >> Sorry. I need a minute. >> He's
taking a minute. He had to walk off.
He had to walk off, guys.
Unlucky. How long we got until he comes >> Possible, but
like
>> Yeah. I mean, I don't I'm I'm trying to be as impartial
as possible, but like I'm I'm waiting to see what happens and
like happened in this meeting since it seems to be like
>> a lynch pin. >> I could show it. I got no problem
with it. Again, I don't mind like saying I fled up. That's definitely
not like what I'm not here to do. >> Yeah. I mean, I either
way, the way this seems now, I don't think there's really a way
to un
>> tie this knot. >> No, there's not. And that's
okay. Go to videos. OBS recordings. Let me find this specific
one
cuz I had done I Okay, let me go to yada yada yada. Oh, >> okay.
How much more of this do we need to watch, do you think? Like
is there good good stuff after this? It's good >> Okay,
so the rest of this and you could probably skip through or speed
it up or whatever. The rest of this, if you want to watch it,
is them watching the previous call that we listen to together.
Um, and then Diesel's basically just calling him out like, "No,
dude. What are you This is a firing call. what are you doing?
Like d stuff like that. >> Okay.
I mean, I'm guessing I feel like I've gotten all I need out of
this. Like I I get that Diesel sort of understands and Val's
like like drowning, >> but where does it go after this?
Where do we get to after this? >> That and do you mean
like other pieces of content?
>> Well, yeah. I'm just curious because I thought there
was a whole bunch of other stuff. I thought I thought you were
like literally weren't you like honey [__] people
in DMs? I thought you were like >> this is this is the
most recent thing. Um I mean what have you guys looked at cuz
you Creamman showed you stuff >> I looked at your tweet.
I looked at your tweet and then we listened to the mod call.
Um I know there's a Queen and Becket call as well.
Fali
hated me so much that he was trying to me and his girlfriend
was trying to me and his girlfriend was saying instead of morale
you should my boyfriend.
So, there's that. >> Okay. Yeah, I want that stuff. I did
get the impression that basically
like Faly was saying you can't bring you're not allowed to bring
Mau up on stream and they were trying to do some whole cope about
how actually Mau viewers are just going to try to get Faly to
say slurs and that's just a terrible, right? That was what I
was hearing. That was just
gone over the IRL friend DMs yet. We've got we've not really
gone over any DMs at all. So, Fali also
on stream. So, when you're ready, I sent you the DM and then
also the stream. Go to 4 hours, 8 minutes. He pulls out his phone.
Pretty cool. >> Okay, hold on. What a total What a degenerate.
Who would do this? What a disgusting freak.
Um, while you're streaming, that's that's bizarre, man. Anyway,
okay. Give me your stream link. I am Am I doing the DMs first?
>> Yeah, you can just go in whatever order you want.
>> Sure. Probably that. Yeah. >> Okay. Is Cloudy.
This is Fal's current partner. I know it's okay. I'm not going
to yell at you. Only going to let you know what happens if he
opens his big dumb mouth. Blank. And that I get it. I love you,
dummy. And whatever you're you're going through sucks. I just
And I wish I could do more, but I genuinely would rather be some
sort of weird stepmom than let moral win. Why are you How are
you in these people's heads?
>> How How do these people even know who you are? This
is uh this is like 3 month sorry this is 2 months ago. >> Oh,
do you want to get into that? Do you want to know why they hate
me?
>> Oh, I do. But let me read the messages >> Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Blank. Like I'm rationalizing it, but it's not helping.
I know a Discord fling isn't worth my marriage.
>> Wait, who's
a queen?
>> Yeah, I know that. I saw that. >> Because when
I when I first got these screenshots, I wanted to keep them private,
but then someone leaked it. the >> Leo would win. Leo would
win. Reena, didn't you give this away? Who this person is? This
the Reena person. >> Oh, that's true. Well, I guess I didn't
censor it all that well anyways.
>> Oh, my bad. >> Sounds good. >> Doesn't matter
now. It's already been leaked, so >> my bad, dude. Okay.
>> Uh, I don't expect you to. Leo would win, Reena. I'm
weak. You going to let the Bible thumper win? I'm going to buy
a plane ticket so you could choke me out. That's just going to
get you get you going, too. Shaking my head. Yeah,
sorry. Continuing true, but you better choke me out. Ralph will
absolutely leak everything you
censoring sure. >> I haven't, by the way, to be clear,
I
>> Okay. Yeah, you're right. Like, it won't even be fun
cheating. Then the hormones are gone and you're left with that.
It's the hair. If I'm being honest, every guy I've dated has
had long hair. Wait, have you sent pictures of yourself to this
>> I don't think so. >> Okay. Why does she think
you have long
flirted too close to the sun.
>> I can tell you in DMs, but I'm not going to say out
loud.
Oh, >> okay. Lau, when will midwhite men suffer? Me when
someone is a little bit goofy and calls me pretty. I'm I'm standards
are in hell. At least find one that buys you stuff.
Trust me, I wouldn't be telling you if I didn't regret it. I'd
rather Fouchy knock you up their morale. Lauo.
Okay, now tell me why do these people hate you? What's going
on here? >> Yeah, I'm going to need to
Okay, so first off, we need this. One sec. So, it starts a year
and a half ago. So, this is going to be like
I think it's like
25 minutes. One second. Yeah. Yeah. So, if you go to 25 minutes
in this, this was my first ever interaction or like witnessing
a Fali. Uh, so in this time stamp, I'll tell you what you're
looking for. So 25 minutes, this guy is accusing uh this brony
guy who like is a weird not trying to defend him, whatever. He's
accusing him of having a uh grooming server. And the evidence
he uses for that >> is a wall of text saying and he asks
this guy saying, "Hey, how could you think people could believe
you don't have a grooming server when things like this are set
in your server?" And then he's he obviously shows this so you
can play that.
>> You also have a different individual. Okay. So, who's
this individual? This is Foster Z Kitten. Is >> this your
name? >> Foster Z kitten kitten? >> Oh, no. That's
Foster's boyfriend. >> Boyfriend. Okay. So, still another
>> And don't let's let's not get out of this for a second.
This is another >> Imagine spamming the word over and over
again in Discord. That's a That's a despicable thing to do. >> In
a child, you have terrible. Truly >> Hold up. Hold up.
>> All right. All right. Okay. >> You have an open
space with adults. Now my question to you is you have adults
and children mixing. Now you have an individual
posting these kind of comments and I hope they're an adult.
You you know these are things I I I want to express to you. If
this is how your Discord is run with rules and a moderator chat,
how can people believe you that this is not a grooming server
>> when there's messages like this?
>> What I would ask anyone is to ask any of the individuals,
is there grooming going >> No, no, no, no, no, no. How
can you No, no, no. I'm asking you a question. Please answer.
>> All right. All right. So, uh, >> so, so, so how
can you verifiably
how can you verifiably ascertain that there is really all you
need? Cuz this is when I clicked off. I was like, "Oh, this is
this guy's trying to do like a pedo expose thing and he's opening
up with this. This is like stupid."
>> this is pretty rough. Yeah, this is pretty rough. >> Yeah.
So, again, this guy's completely Yeah, completely guilty. Whatever.
>> But I was talking [__] on him in this stream.
He is in chat and he's like, "Oh, I'll call in and argue with
you." I was like, "Okay, sure." And he's like, "Uh, I think at
the beginning he's like, "Oh, well, you need to show me a clip
or whatever." And I was like, "Okay, let me go grab the clip."
Uh, so I read out the transcript to him. So, this is me unmuting
uh to read out the transcript and then begin arguing with him.
>> [__] We were supposed to play Minecraft
together. >> He wanted 25 minutes. Oh, go ahead. Sorry.
Sorry. Sorry. >> Go ahead. No, no, go ahead. You're good.
>> So, around 25 minutes, uh, you have an open space with
adults. Now, my question to you is while you have adults and
children mixing, you have an individual posting these kind of
comments. Uh I hope they're an adult and you know these things.
I want to press it to you uh that this is your Discord. I'm reading
the transcript, so this could be
uh blah blah blah blah wall of text, whatever. So, yeah, you
are attributing the the wall of text saying to to a form of grooming.
Um >> Okay. So you say, and I quote, at least from the
transcript, uh, how can people believe uh that this is not a
grooming uh server with
attributing the screenshot of the wall? >> Is that Zyl
like the Zyl who hangs out in with Nicholas Jorio? And
That's what I I stopped watching at that point because I was
like, this is >> Yeah. I what I would suggest is that you
should watch the rest of it because there's instances where a
13-year-old literally says I'm 13
and somebody going into that uh in the same public forum saying
I'm 13 I'm mentally 13 but I'm physically 25. Is that okay with
you?
>> Sure. I I I don't think that necessarily invalidates
like this being kind of a point. Right. I'm I I'm not going to
argue that with you because I think that that's stupid if you're
not going to watch the whole video if I'm going to be real because
I literally am sitting there with a wall of text and him talking
about how he's uh wants to create a >> Do you think a wall
of text saying is like equivalent to >> Again, if you're
not going to watch if if you're not going to watch the whole
interview, I don't know what to tell you. You're saying you're
saying to me you don't want to watch the whole interview. If
you also heard the fact that he wants to create a safe space
cuz part of that as well was saying he wants adults who are attracted
to minors.
>> Okay, I'll watch the whole interview, but I'm just asking
you very simply. Do you think a wall of text saying rip in a
server with minors is equivalent to a grooming tactic?
>> Do you know how grooming works?
>> Why are you unwilling to answer >> I'm I'm not
I'm not >> I've asked this like three times at this >> I'm
not unwilling to answer the question. I'm asking, do you understand
how grooming works? Yes or no? It's just a yes or I'm not even
>> I've asked my >> Yes, this is Bali who's talking
to >> question three times. I'm not going to do the the
weird back and forth. You can answer mine and then I'll participate
in the conversation. >> Dude, he breathes deep into his
mic. I keep hearing him sigh like every time he's done speaking.
>> listen to that. Listen. No, no, no. >> Question
three times. I'm not going to do the the weird back and forth.
>> Did you not hear him breathe out there?
You can answer mine and then I'll participate in the conversation.
>> No. No.
because
it's okay. >> Yeah, we're not going to get anywhere then.
I think it's to claim that this is equivalent to a grooming tactic.
>> Okay. And if you understand that part of grooming is
making minors feel more comfortable and lowering the inhibition
to conversations and there's people that are self-proclaiming
they're as young as 14, 13 in that server, I don't really know
what to tell you. >> Yeah. I mean, you can watch the rest
of this child,
>> but this is like this is why he dislikes me. He he saw
that I was chatting. >> He came on >> Uh he didn't
like that I like disagreed with him here. Um so basically over
the course of like this like when this was uploaded or when this
was streamed or whatever and um like now basically he's been
like in his private servers in DMs of several people like talking
me for this. Um so he ever since this he's just not liked me.
Uh, in fact, I might be able to grab this for you. Um, he's like,
he has DMs where he's like, um,
here. He's like, I only keep him around cuz I think he's going
to try to with me. It's like really bizarre, like hyper paranoid.
I think Ralph is hitting on me. He'll probably back off since
he knows I'm married, but we'll update if he keeps being weird.
K. Kid is an idiot. I foresee af allegation in his
If only she knew.
>> I If she bothered to look you up, she'd see one in your
past. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Um I'm not sorry. That
is technically accurate. But
also, what why why do girls always go for the bad boy? She's
I see a fest allegation. His future starts with morale. Why did
she do that? >> I don't understand. I don't know if I just
have like the charisma of a Greek god or if women are just like
really desperate. It's like super easy. I don't know what I'm
doing.
>> You just ask multiple times. Eventually, they just say
yes. >> I usually like I threaten to dox them and like,
you know, stuff like that as well and it gets them to say yes
pretty quick as well. >> Damn, that's crazy.
Okay. All right. Now,
we went through all of these DMs, were we? No, we're not. We
got So, then they start
Uh, in >> so this is on stream. This is on stream. >> yes.
Okay.
>> The link I sent you. Go to 4 hours and 8 minutes. Whenever
you're ready. >> 4 hours and 8 minutes.
Let's see here. 4 hours 8 minutes >> for sure.
I think that Sacramento
>> wait until he pulls out his phone >> mentally
like when he left
>> his phone >> like I've [__] >> Oh,
it becomes obvious. Don't worry. >> And we heard it in
the straight up >> Well, attempted, right? Um >> I'll
make it difficult for you to see anyone else. Girl, get the [__]
out of here. You were mad as [__] >> Like,
shut up. And I think that I think that Left for Dead
saw this. I think she she wanted the money and she wanted fame
and she she
saw this. >> So that's when he gets the uh the ass pick.
It's awesome.
>> Hold on. Did I see this in the
Hey babe? Tis focus on stream. Make me not. I like that. Like
a tease. Huh? I do. Some say some say need it. Guess what color
my underwear are. And if you get it right, I'll let you see them.
Red. You got me. Nope. Gray. And then I'm guessing right after
gray. Yeah.
>> Yep. I'm assuming anyways. Yeah. Um, obviously I've
not been sent any revenge or anything like that.
>> But yeah. So, and I I want to clarify that because his
server is like convinced I have a picture of his. I don't know
why. Um.
>> Very important. You do not have a picture of his.
I don't, but I will post it if he does not make a response to
my liking.
>> You always do this. You say, "I I would never do that."
And then you say the thing. It's crazy, man.
>> Because it's funny.
>> This is him talking about the Sly boy stuff. I think
I saw this earlier. >> Hey, Fatty at the OP block. Why
can't you take the L publicly? You're such a spineless.
So, when it comes to Sly Boy, I can absolutely take the L on
not reading into and determining it was about the thumbnail.
When he made the initial post, he did not include that it was
for the thumbnail. I quickly went into an online exam and saw
that he had made a video later specifying it was about the thumbnail
an hour later. The main focus of my clarifying tweet was that
I felt her continued attempt to poison the well with a content
creator or sorry with a creator who covered the situation showed
continued malent
malicious intent. I guess I'm trying to
I don't think this is a this is not a word. Mal intent. I don't
think >> if only Queenland was here, he'd have the time
of his life with this. >> Mal,
there's mal content. Hold on. Let me let me just check because
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure that's not a word. Oh, hold on.
It's considered a valid English word, but I It usually is a dash.
Oh, yeah. It's supposed to have a dash. Yeah. Okay. Mal intent
could be something.
No dash. Unlucky. Wait, I didn't finish this. Okay. Um,
mountain tent. I completely acknowledge she was within her rights
to take the thumbnail down at the very least under YouTube to
Okay. So, he wouldn't post this publicly. This is in some private
server or something. Some private >> uh this is in someone's
DMs who leaked me. Um, uh, Reena's DMs, in fact. But yeah. Yeah.
So, again, this all started out as uh the doxing thing cuz I
was like, "This guy's like and whatever." And then I got like
a few leaks of him like being two-faced to Becket, to Malcolm,
and to me, uh, like talking but then nice to your face, whatever.
>> And then also, do you do you know the uh the Himpleton
uh stale uh interview that he did where Fali came on to debate
him?
>> Okay. So, um
I mean, yeah, self-explanatory. Uh Fali went on to debate him
and I was watching this debate and I thought that uh Fali was
constantly trying to get this guy into like gotchas. He was constantly
trying to do uh whatever D and um he
was just like punching down in my opinion and I thought that
was like super pathetic. So I DM'd Templeton. I was like, "Hey,
can I come on and like uh like 2v1 uh Fali? Can I like argue
on behalf of Stale Side because I don't think he's arguing well."
Uh, and I did. And um, uh, Fali was like completely and the moment
he was arguing with someone like barely competent because I'm
not a good debater. Um, you've heard me argue. I'm pretty bad
actually. Um, but the moment he was uh, you know, facing off
against someone like barely competent, he was just floundering.
So, this is a clip from him.
>> You're not a particularly bad debater. I don't know
why you think that. Not compared to the average person. Wasn't
that your Wasn't that what you were like really famous for in
my Discord at first was debating people?
>> is that like how you built a reputation? >> I
tried to I would lose like constantly.
>> Oh, I didn't know that. >> Stale, I have another
question for you. Is that okay?
>> If a woman is cheated on several times by several different
partners and she has to succumb to the advances of a man uh who
only will do poly relationships, what do you think about the
uh what do you think about that? >> It's a pretty meme.
It's a pretty It's like sounds like a Reddit story is is what
it says. >> Sounds like a Reddit story.
>> Just using this guy's like life story to talk right
now.
>> Uh yeah. Yeah. Because So I can try to find the the
other clip uh of him like chatting to me. But I So the the reason
I join and I'll I'll multitask and try to uh find this for you.
The reason I joined uh like the the the tipping point for me
was um
Stale saying that he trusts AI moderation on YouTube and then
Fali responds saying, "Oh, well, didn't the Grock Twitter bot
generate a ton of child? So, why do you trust AI?" I joined and
then I started arguing with him on that, which I can find. I
call him fat and then he says I messaged a 17-year-old and then
I uh
talk about his poly relationship and he gets like salty and bitter.
Unlike relationship >> or that story would be more Reddit.
Who's the more Reddit?
>> We'll ask relation r/ relationship
>> I think I will I think I might ask r/ relationships
advice. Thank you style.
>> Dude, Hamilton's just laughing. >> It's like a
Reddit story is is what it >> Sounds like Reddit story.
>> Do you think you or that story would be more Reddit?
Who's the more Reddit?
>> We'll ask relation relationship advice. >> Hima
is trying not to laugh in this. It's very funny. He's just like
trying. He's He's trying to bite his tongue right now. Not Not
laugh at Algae openly. Goofy stuff. Goofy goofy stuff. >> So,
because of this, um
I can try to to dig up the DMs if you want to see them. Um but
because of this, uh he tries to DM Reena and guilt trip her and
to stop watching my streams and like talking to me. Uh because
I was mean to Cloudy here. uh because she's friends with Cloudy,
his girlfriend,
or was at this time. Uh he's like, "Hey, I don't care about this,
but Cloudy's your friend, right? So, you should care about this."
Like stuff like that, >> Uh so that that's what happened
after this, which is ultimately what led her to uh leak a bunch
of to me. And then I started leaking it. Um it was after the
docs thing. The docs thing is really what tipped uh tipped her.
And then I was like, "Yeah, dude. I hate this guy. He's like
lying about the doc." But yeah, here's a clip.
>> Okay. All right. >> I don't like you bringing
like a purple perry or something, right? >> No, I'm not
listen.
>> Why? He just makes up names of people. Why is he trying
to go on on streams like this and then he's like, I don't want
to talk to Perry. Is he just working his way down to like lower
and lower? Okay. Lower and lower viewership streams. No, no offense.
No offense to Hamilton. Him's Him's cool in my opinion. Okay.
Love Hamilton. I'm just saying why why is he just like well I
can't I can't talk to Perry cuz he used to say he could talk
to me or Queenman too and now he's like I don't want you to add
like a purple Perry or something.
>> I'm assuming it's cuz Perry's tried to with him or something.
I don't know. >> And now eventually he'll be on like some
three viewer streamer stream and he'll be like don't add Himleton.
I don't want to talk to somebody like Hamilton. >> It's
very weird. Sorry I'm going to let >> I don't agree
context. >> Uh he thought I was Doomer Media throughout
this entire call. Uh, even at the end he started leaking DMs
with Doomer Media thinking I was Doomer Media on an alt account.
Uh, so >> wait,
sorry. Uh, Fouchy thought that or Stale thought that? >> Stale
thought that. >> Oh, very goofy. Okay, >> let's see
if he picks up. This guy was literally just begging to be in
the >> Oh, we got a got a GSDLK viewer here.
>> I think he's I think he's >> Wait,
I know who this guy is. Eix the video. Wait. >> Well, his
name is Moral, but I think on Twitter he goes by Doomer Media.
Yeah. >> Did he make a Vos's Unradically Evil?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Oh, you're I honestly didn't watch it. >> You're
scaring me. >> I didn't watch it actually, but I heard
people watching it. Yeah. So, I know. >> Yeah. It was It
was probably the definitive Vospiece for a while.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You made the rounds, dude. Good job.
>> Good to see you, buddy. I'm guessing that you're aware
that that is literally something Doomer used to say. >> Yeah,
that's why I said it. >> Okay. All right. All right. Okay.
Yeah. I just wasn't sure.
>> Sorry. I was playing Metro. I don't know. I was listening
like 5 minutes ago. I don't What's going on now? >> Oh
my god. I brought you in because I said that you disagree with
Fion stuff and you agree on sale with stuff but wanted to push
back. What's up? >> Oh well, I mainly disagreed on the
Gro AI child thing. I thought that was like cuz you were talking
about like YouTube moderation AI, not generative AI. Two >> but
the the question but the question was the question was AI doesn't
have a fallibility when there's an there's evidence of AI having
fallibility or it has less fallibility than humans, >> right?
There's instances of like saying people are evil and then you're
responding okay well black people whatever. Like these are two
different types of AI, two different types of things, right?
>> Okay. Uh again I I I Because I disagree.
>> Use generative AI. We're talking about AI moderation
tools, right? >> I I >> You can disagree, but you're
also like a fat [__]
>> So, it's okay if you disagree. >> Yeah. And you
and you and you 17year-olds. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. >> Yeah.
And you >> Why are you mean, man? Why you got to be mean
with this guy?
>> Cuz dude, I thought that Okay, I cannot tell you how
stupid I thought his AI point was. Okay. >> Okay. I had
to like go and find like an abused girl who you could cheat on
because she was like cheated on 10
>> Sorry. That's [__] up. Why would you Why
would you do that? >> Go and find like an What do you want
from You want me to like lay down belly up when people bring
that [__] up? No, I'm going to escalate.
>> we can have a debate about AI. We can have a debate
about the AI.
>> You escalated on on someone who's not in the conversation.
Jesus, man. She was like cheated on 10 times. >> What are
we doing? >> Are you Are we doing this?
>> Can we not Can we just avoid Can we Can we do substantive
Can we do substantive >> Substantive. Listen, I can roll
around in the dirt, fy, if you want to start going there. >> I
don't think we need to roll. >> Totally joking with you.
>> You were joking. Oh, >> we don't need to roll
around in the dirt. We don't need to roll around. >> Yeah,
I'm just joking with you. I'm just [__] around. >> That's
okay. It was a joke that you seek out like abused women WHO WERE
CHEATED.
>> Just to be clear. >> Ah, I see. I see you. Lot
of lot of hard feelings, bud. This is really sad. I thought Oh,
I thought I thought we were I thought we were closer than this.
>> Lot of hard feelings, dude. I come in here, I disagree
with one point and I lay out how these two things are like separated,
right? Like one of them is generative AI and one of them is people
using generative AI to make, you know, probably bad things, right?
And one of them is AI moderation. And you're like, >> can
Stale top? Can Stale stop touching his lip like this like a giant
baby? Can he stop? He needs to stop. Why can it not stop? It
needs to stop. It needed to stop a long time ago. Dude, he's
just He's doing it the whole time. Look. Look at THE WHAT ARE
YOU DOING?
What the fuck?" >> I think he's happy. I think he's happy
cuz he thinks that Doomer media is coming in to defend him. I
think that's what he thinks.
probably bad things, right? And one of them is AI moderation.
And you're like, "Okay, well, I just disagree." I'm like, "Okay,
well, you're kind of like a for thinking that." >> I could
I could dis I could disagree. That's okay. That's And I just
said that I disagree. >> You can disagree, but if I say
the sky is blue, and you say, "Well, I think it's red. I just
disagree." Then you're probably a idiot, right? >> Okay.
Okay. I I got a riddle for you. Okay. I conundrum because I was
I was asked this. Um let's say you report somebody because you
think they're breaking the rules. Is that okay? >> Is this
for foul game? >> No, this is for No, this is I'm asking
you, buddy. Me? I think someone broke the rules. Yeah. Oh, >> this
is about the whole Perry thing in general. I got >> You
can report them. Who cares? >> Whoa. But how do you know
if they broke the rules? You just think that, sir? >> Uh
yeah, I think like 99.9% of people aren't analyzing the to determine
if someone did or didn't break the rules. Usually, they're just
reporting like
>> Okay, so there that's a better one. But I guess does
that mean that like you can't report anybody cuz you're you're
is that a false report? Are you if you think that somebody broke
the rules? Is >> a false report? No. A false report
>> Okay. I don't need too much more of this. You This is
why Fali is another reason Fali hates you up until this moment
in time. Do you have the Did you send me the DMs? >> No.
I can find them though. Um >> horrifying. Truly horrifying.
This Jesus. Okay,
so DMs, what did you say happened in the DMs? It's basically
he's now pressuring the Rena person to stop talking to you.
>> Uh yeah, let me find it. >> I have it. Let me
see the diesel stuff as well. Right. >> I wonder if there's
anything else in your timeline that I didn't catch.
>> Doomer Media. Oh, I'm going to be scrolling past a bunch
of ass, too. God damn it. You don't retweet nudes, right? It's
just like Luds.
>> Me? No. I mean, sometimes I uh quote retweet uh Pinky
Chow because I think it's funny. >> Yeah, that's what I'm
saying is like I've seen some of the Pinky the Pink Chu quote
tweets that >> seen those.
This is what he DM'd her right after
>> or like around the time. I don't know if it's like right
after, but um yeah, so he so she tries to change the conversation
a lot, but he keeps bringing me up. So he's like she whatever.
I mean, you can just read them say it. >> Yeah, the beef
started with Dan's burst well with morale. I think it's funny
because I think I'm one of the few people to give him grace with
his cam video. God, the cam stuff was wild. I'm still not over
the gut coverage. Haha. I mean, if wants to just constantly target
Cloudy. That's up to him. Yeah, it's a city to target people's
partners, but it's the sphere, I guess. Lol. I mean, that's your
guy, JK. My guy, huh? Haha. Just poke in front of me, dude.
Uh, well, very funny. >> So, do you see why I would read
that maybe as a bit manipulative? Yeah, there's like so I mean
are they partners
>> Uh they were
um yeah there there's the DMs of Cloudy like encouraging her
and whatever. So yeah, they were um not anymore.
>> Cool, cool, cool, cool. I feel like this is not like
a weird thing if you have like some intimate relationship to
to say these kinds of things, but it's it's manipulative. It's
just like sort of a like a manipulative thing that most people
will do with their close with people close to them that I don't
necessarily think is wrong, but it is manipulative. I'd also
think it's manipulative, but it's like sort of accepted in a
what do you call it? A monogous relationship that like, hey,
I might not want you to hang out with this person and you sort
of accept that in a poly relationship of some kind. I would assume
this these feelings have to be done away with that like you can't
be >> sex. That's what you're saying, I think. >> No,
no, no, no. Well, that yeah, never mind. Then that's that was
why I asked originally if they weren't >> sex at some point.
So on the streams whenever she would show up in chat, he would
DM her to start. Uh so she stopped watching him and eventually
said, "Hey, I want to stop doing anything." Uh and they're like,
"Okay, still friends." And he was like, "Yeah, still friends."
Uh so they are still friends, but they stopped at this point.
>> got it. Weird.
A lot of weird people out here. A lot of weird people doing >> Not
me, though. Not moral. Not moral. He just wants to play Zomboid.
>> I'm playing Satisfactory now.
>> Okay. Ralph's inside sources revealed that Oplock Fali
was so terrified of the lemur that he edited out mentions from
his VOD. He accidentally pulled up a conspiracy lemur tweet.
He got so scared that after the stream, he went into YouTube
studio and edited that part out, >> which is why now I
don't know what stream this how he, you know, doesn't uh like
mentioned on his streams, how he'll berate his co-hosts uh for
bringing me up on streams and stuff like that. He doesn't like
drama clipping Twitter accounts on his uh stream,
which is why, now I don't know what stream this is. I don't know
what stream this is, but he pulled up uh presumably accidentally
a uh a conspiracy lemur tweet and he got so scared that after
the stream he had to he went through the VOD through YouTube
Studio and he apparently, according to my source, edited the
part out where he looked at a conspiracy lemur tweet because
he didn't want to give them attention on his 100 viewer >> Wow.
How he
what a guy so scared of conspiracy lemur. Uh oh.
So scared of conspiracy lemur. I didn't I missed this one. It's
too bad.
Calls out art content art. What is this? Commentary community
40-year-old unic block at the opblock and says he will leak well
I maybe covered these ones. says, "You will leak messages every
day for a month if the latter doesn't admit to lying. Plus, it
doesn't respond to the Twitter video." I remember that.
Hold on. >> I was completely lying about that, by the way.
I [__] all dude, I have completely just my way through
this entire inter uh this entire drama. Um I've basically just
pretended that I've had a ton of stuff to leak, which other people
saw and was like, "Oh, I want to get ahead of this, so let me
leak
Um,
so I I just made up. I just made up. I didn't even know that
Diesel and uh Fali had like a falling out really. I mostly just
made that up and I put together like context clues and and said
that uh which led to that call um you know probably being leaked.
Uh so
>> Wow. You manufactured this out of >> Five screenshots.
Yeah, I had like five screenshots in total. >> I don't
know what this is. Is this meant to be?
What is this meant to be? >> Oh, I I just really hate the
Silent Hill 2 remake. It's I It's like a gay art thing. Yeah.
>> Lol. Can I >> uh Oh, yeah. You can click that.
That's OP block.
>> Oh, five Oh, 500 subs.
>> Yeah, click on that. >> He's losing subs here.
Oh. Uh
why? You could have war. You could have warned, man. This guy
thinks he's funny. This guy thinks he's really funny.
Listen, it's cool when Liam does it, not when he does it. Okay?
>> It's also not cool when Liam does it, but it's not cool
when Liam does it because people are too turned on. When it's
it's not cool when Fali does it because it's repulsive. Okay,
>> that's why people get way too into the That is a horrifying
Dickers emote that Reinhardt just threw in the chat. That is
a horrifying thing.
Dickers would have that emote. That is Dude, what is what is
Liam Donovan doing? What is he doing? Why is he trying to like
roll with this? Why is he putting this stuff out still?
And by the way, on Instagram for free, like at least start a
fansly. At least start like an only fans or something and make
some money. You know, you could cash in. Just cash in. No. Why
is he not cashing in?
>> How does drama content keep giving to >> I couldn't
tell you.
Not going to lie, it's kind of fun watching people self- emilate
for no discernable reason. The Fouchy guy. The streaming drama
has taught me one thing. It's to make sure to go out in style.
Wow. Oh, that's Cloudy with BB No Money. What the
>> What the Okay.
>> Oh, this guy used to be like a Hassan mega fan. >> The
Fouchy guy.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I haven't sent you that [__]
Let me grab >> apologize to your husband instead. You should
also apologize to moral for lying to him while you're at it.
And to everyone else for trying to paint your actions as for
the hurt people when it's clear you just like getting the attention
of e boys. You one man. I'm sorry. This is Reena B. Spleen.
Do you care if I let him know Leo got booted out of the server
or keep that to myself for now? Well, him being booted is not
public. Him leaving can be cuz you say you can say you noticed
it. Can I say I made Leo leave? JK JK. I'll leave it for now.
Up to you. You can say you notice. I don't mind. I'll let you
say something first and go with whatever you say. Uh, you can
say it. I don't care. I trust you. If anything, you can identify
that I discussed that I've spoken with him about his spur behavior
and what my line was, which included that among other things.
I don't know if it's super interesting, but Leo isn't in the
OP server anymore. Kicked or left. It might be because of what
happened yesterday. I think left. I haven't seen him. I haven't
seen anything about him getting kicked, but he isn't there anymore.
Do I got a question? Okay.
Oh, you know these people well enough to go over this?
It's crazy.
Well, I She just randomly DM'd me with it. I was like, "Okay,
I'm I guess I'm
sure if he's been kicked. I want to know the the scoop, but it's
not like I'm fiending for information about Lio. I don't really
care."
>> And then it goes to That's all I said. And then I pointed
him to the channel spat kas. I don't care to mention. Is that
fine? Linking to him to it is fine. I don't think you did anything
wrong.
Good guy, Lio. Uhoh. Wait, this is from August 15th, 2025.
>> How did I miss this? I don't I'm just reposting that
because it's funny. Let's
Why did Cloudy leak this about at the oplog? He wants women to
talk like about their stories while he them. Is that about Is
that going to be about the op block or is that really about you
moral? Tell me the truth.
Tell me the truth, bro. >> Wow. Wow.
Uh here, let me uh I'll send you something. Um >> hold
on. I got I got send another set of messages real quick. Actually,
these are
>> Wait, these are from the same thing.
>> Yeah. No, no, it's it's 100% about you. God damn it.
>> Oh, yeah. >> Lol. Help. I'm ovulating. Lauo, you
don't understand. It's so bad. I'm sweating and I'm falling from
Reena. No, don't go where I can't follow. You can make fun of
me. It's okay. He wants women to talk about their stories while
he them crying.
I know. That's the crazy part is I know he's a and it's not worth
it. But I'm so damn bad right now. I like need someone to slap
some sense into me. Physically slap me. Lauo. I'm not even joking
when I say ovulating. Like I'm cramping, dude. It gets so bad.
Lau, but there's other. Anyone else? Truth. This is This is crazy.
Do we have Do we have a face reveal on Reno? Do we know what
Reena looks like?
>> I don't know if it's public. Um >> Well, sorry.
I'm not asking you for private photos. I'm asking literally if
it's in public. >> I don't want to see private I don't
want to see anything like that. I'm just >> No, I'm I do
not know. So, the answer is no. I'm not going to send anything.
>> I'm not asking you to say I'm making it clear. I'm not
asking you to send >> To be abundantly clear, I don't know.
I I do not think that you're asking. I do not think you're asking.
The answer to your question is I don't know. Therefore, I'm not
going to send anything. I don't think you're asking me. I'm just
saying >> no, probably not. I don't know. Thank you for
making it clear. Happy selfie day, everyone. I'm still waiting
on more wedding pics to trickle around, but I thought this was
a fun one of eating cake mango moose for my swagapinos.
Hassan the han, not hassan baby hassiab.
Not sure how to say that one. Has Twitter selfie day # Hassan
Twitter selfie day.
Wow, he used to look different.
Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. One more. Like I know Cloudy and I make the
joke that we went through the Hassan stuff, but healthcare is
the one thing I always argue with people on because socialized
medicine cannot be instituted in the states because it is a job
sector.
Wow. Instituted. Instituted.
>> So I don't know anything about this, but I've been told
that that's a take. >> That is a job sector, so you can't
do Yeah, it doesn't make any sense. I mean, you might it might
be job contraction, but it's like there is just a lot of waste
there, a lot of profit seeking, like rent seeeking stuff going
on.
It it might not be like simple, but you could still do it. I
don't know why you're sending me his >> doesn't distinguish
it from from anything else either, right? >> This is from
his uh chats on server.
>> Everything is a jobs sector. It's like why would why
would healthcare
>> not be socialized cuz it's a jobs
Um, you could still give people jobs. Yeah, works out very well.
>> Anyway,
food picks, master cheffing, pandemic cooking, more food, more
food.
>> the Hassan logs.
Is it just him posting food in the Hassan server? That's a >> So,
the way Hassan server works is you need to have like a certain
amount of like exp to be able to see everything. So, this is
all that I could see upon joining. Um, I didn't care enough to
like message a user and be like, "Hey, could you search this
guy's name and [__] find me or whatever." >> Too
bad. >> But yeah, he probably has more. Maybe he doesn't.
I don't know. I Maybe if someone uh is in Hassan's server and
has like exp points, you could uh figure it
>> You could one could.
All right. I think that is that it? That's it for That's it.
That's all. Well, I I there's the queening combo with Becket,
but I might save that for tomorrow. >> There's
nothing. You could probably end off with that. Sure.
>> Well, I'm probably going to do that tomorrow once I
Now I'm caught up. Now I can watch the Becket Queen and call
be >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
You might want to see a bit of Becket stream to get an idea.
>> well, hold on. What do you mean you want to see Beckett's
stream? Which Becket stream link? >> The Becket stream
from last night for whatever. It's just the last stream on his
channel. Watch some of his intro when his cam's on. That's the
way he talks about this drama.
>> Why do you just hate Beckett? Can you just chill?
>> I can see you. You're like visualizing in your head
and seething already before he's done anything. You like see
this image and you're instantly like turning
>> I I can see it. I can hear it in your
>> What do you think about that? Good evening, Quan. What
do you think about that? Was that rough?
Is that tough to >> That's not Look, that's not what we're
here for. Welcome in. Welcome in. Now
go on. Get comfy. Grab a seat. Make sure you got a snack. 300
of you in waiting.
300 of you in waiting. Okay. Okay.
Hell. Nice to see you guys. Nice to see you. See you. Nice.
Oh, well guys, you >> he covers the gayest drama all the
time and gets so many viewers for it. It just it I literally
I can't even with the art community drama and it's like because
it's this FGI guy. 9,000 views on this
9,000. How many concurrents did he have for this stream? Like
800. >> No one even watches Fei, man. No one even watches
FI streams. They only watch Fi when he's like >> in like
some big ACC drama. And yet they will show up for this.
>> It's crazy. He gets so many viewers. >> You know,
>> I just asked Becc if I could stream snipe him and he
said yes and I got like 100 concurrent because of it. It was
thought I like I've had a couple of days. I've had longer than
>> No, I hold on. I could definitely I know people who
could Becket would tell me about art commentary drama. >> Becket
would come on. He would talk about it. bunch of people come and
talk about it. They love nothing more than talking about it.
THEY LOVE IT. MOR'S RIGHT HERE. >> I DON'T WANT TO do it.
I don't care. >> Yeah. No one with above 90 IQ can listen
to it. So
>> I don't I literally would rather invested in >> Listen,
I I'll sit here and I'll rant about Israel for like 16 hours,
but you asked me to figure out who these Discord people are and
I'm like I just can't I can't imagine >> yourself actually.
I can't I can't imagine it >> than that actually in some
respects
to consider how to begin even talking about this complete and
utter show.
>> The only the only things I found compelling about this
are like when I heard Mau was like having to this guy to get
leaks to further the drama. I'm like, "Oh, now I'm like a little
bit interested. Everybody talking about on the sidelines, I just
couldn't do it, man. I couldn't." Yeah. >> He says he's
cool in with me basically.
What's that?
>> I I asked moral if he had if he manipulated this woman's
get list. Says >> I don't I don't remember that. I don't
Okay. And I Listen, I don't remember that. Okay. I don't >> I
can send I can send the time stamp. Rough time stamp.
>> Listen, this girl made me like a Castle Crashers like
avatar thing. Okay. She's awesome. She's my head moderator, too.
I'm sure no issues will come with that. It's going to be epic.
Did you Did you just have this time stamp ready to go? You're
like, I I'll send a time stamp. The time stamp was already in
my >> I have I have the rough time stamp for the calling.
I was away for a bit. Did you get the uh
Did you get the Queen and fan DM? >> That that mean husband
watches you. >> I didn't get it, but I've seen it before.
Yeah.
>> Imagine finding out your wife cheated on you uh by watching
Kiman. >> Wait,
no. It's Reena's
Wait, what? Say that again. >> Was it that? Yeah. Yeah,
that Rita's husband. Yeah. >> Yeah, that's how her husband
found out. Oh,
from a Queen's stream. Oh, no,
dude. And you know, it' be rough cuz he's probably >> There's
another message as well where she's like I don't know what Mal's
leaking about this woman or if she even knows what she's leaking,
but apparently her and her husband were like separating at one
point or something. There's like a message about that somewhere.
Oh boy.
I just I can just see that that this this guy sees his wife get
brought up on stream that she's cheating and Queen starts going
on a rant about what a loser this guy is and how he should like
kill himself immediately.
>> This guy what a what a day. >> This guy also apparently
no this guy I was saying this guy's awesome because he was apparently
she's begging for and begging him to buy her flowers and begging
him to take her out and he won't. So he's he's he's awesome.
Wow. Okay. I can't do I'm not waiting for this call in. We need
a better time stamp. I'm going to go through. >> Yeah,
the call in starts like around
>> All right. All right. >> It is really hard to
know where to begin. So, let's let's begin with some health cleaning.
Um, tonight, this will probably not be the last time I talk about
this.
Might be. God, we might get really lucky. But, uh, I'm probably
not really going to talk about the allegations
cuz I have other things to go over. I'll be honest, some of the
stuff that is coming out is the product of drama that has dragged
out since August of last year. There is enough here to talk about
that I am exhausted by to probably not need to go into every
bit of detail cuz we here all night. I've got I've got two calls
to show you. I've got I've got stuff that you guys have not seen
yet. I am going to lay out a huge amount of information for you.
Okay.
So, for those of you who had brooms ready, little little broom
emojis
um on either side, um I am going to disappoint you because I'm
not here to Dude, can we get can we get like some is there like
a fence emote that we could have for Becket? If any If you think
I'm taking somebody's side Oh, yeah. There's a fencer. Yeah.
Yeah, sure. If there's If you think I'm taking a side on this,
okay, if you think I'm taking a side,
>> I'm not. No way. >> No, he he does cover he does
he does kind of take a side, but
>> okay.
Sweet for Falgi.
Um I'm going to be honest with you,
somebody who is a friend of mine has been slandered
and has been lied about >> and has been done incredibly
dirty behind the scenes to an extent that I didn't even realize.
And I am, I'm going to be honest, furious. So,
a lot of what we're going to be talking about tonight is Killjoy
because what has happened
with KJ
is totally
I literally do not know how else to put
I the I have spoken to people if my
>> I think isn't isn't KJ a researcher for Becket too.
>> Yeah. Clipper or something.
>> Yeah. So it's like one of his employees. He's obviously
going to try to clear things for like his employees getting lied
about.
>> Okay. The reason be okay's
going to be a little
gay guy about this. The reason he's upset is because uh Killjoy
does like commissioned uh research, right? Um >> the whole
stream is just like Becket just like
>> I should have stepped in. I should have stepped in.
He does it for Ash, too. He does the exact same thing. >> Becket
is gay about it, but his reasoning is not gay. He is gay about
it, but his reasoning is not gay. >> There's a complaint
here, but making the whole 6hour stream. I can't I can't believe
FG did this to you. I should have been there. >> I agree.
I agree. >> Embarrassing. It's so [__] >> It's
a self-hating. We know this. Okay.
>> Can we just let Bro talk for two
>> I like the verbal battle. It's fine. Um,
so commissioned research. Uh, Cloudy and
[__] what's his name? Faly. Uh, Claudia and Fali
were like spreading that this guy was like a doxer and a scammer
and would repackage research and steal research to sell it and
stuff like that. Uh, so in terms of like a researcher getting
those allegations spread about them, like they'll dox people
and they'll steal research and resell it and they'll scam and
stuff like that. Uh, yeah, there's like a reason to be upset
there. I do agree with Quean in that Beckett's reaction is a
bit like gay, but
um I don't think I've ever seen a piece of content where Becket
like isn't a bit of gay. So, I don't know. It's kind of like
worse than usual. This is way worse than usual. >> Well,
here's the hypothetical. Let's say that Beckett got Killiljoy
or somebody around Becket got Killjoy to do research where there
were docs like included in the research because the research
is about somebody who's like doxing or something like hypothetically
then if if because of that he's being smeared as a doxer wouldn't
that be like annoying and as somebody who's like related to him
financially who either does contracts him for work or helps him
get contract work. Wouldn't you want to clear that up? Would
you feel like it's incumbent on you to clear that up? >> Yeah,
that one said you shouldn't clear
Okay, fair enough. It's just that he keeps hammering it like
>> I'm never going to watch the whole six hour stream.
So >> the way he's treating it though the whole time is
just is just totally shameful. There's like literally I should
I should have stepped in. If you wanted to step in just just
say just literally FG on stream. That's what I say to him. Just
like F on stream the moment it's a problem. Why is you're like
oh it's been dragged out for months. Why? Why don't just rip
the bandit off earlier? You sure you could have done this earlier?
You could have done the stream when it happened. No. Like why
is this I understand why
you know it all has to be this big trauma. Why can't you just
address these things when they happen now? You're like I've got
to explain so much information and I've had to go around and
talk to everyone is like just address the things as they come.
But you've sat s I guess.
>> Yep. Yep. >> If my voice sounds a bit gone, it
is because I have spent a lot of time talking to people trying
to work out what the is going on. Uh, I have learned things that
I was completely unaware of. I have learned >> Beckett
is like the only thing even close to approximating a father figure
like anybody in this community has. He's the only person who
could hold down like a real job outside of this. Like a real
actual job, not like a, you know, I'm not like a barely sentient
job. Like I think he's actually got a real job where he's required
to think thoughts. You know what I mean? So that's probably why
he has to he has to go through and like both mother and father
this entire community all the time >> before you that this
is all happening.
>> Oh wow. That's crazy. But he I think it's like it's
wild to me that he has to have private conversations on all this.
Yes, you could just have like a public conversation. Just get
people to discuss it publicly. I unless there's some sensitive
information, but it doesn't sound like that. He's about to talk
about it on stream. He's about to lay out all the information.
So, I don't >> things that have been said about >> it's
always like this guy when it comes to the like this with this
guy when it comes to ACC stuff. It's always like I've been going
around talking to everyone and oh there there's a lot of parties
involved and this person's been reallyed over. I can't believe
the way they've beened over. It's always like this. It's like
it's all the time. >> Well, it's not your content.
What do you This is what they like. >> It's not about the
It's not about the content, dude. It's not about the content
cuz this guy swears by this stuff.
He actually thinks this way. That's the problem.
Yeah, but I'm telling you that's why he's popular with these
people. It's because he thinks this way. >> I got a problem
with that.
>> You've got a problem with the ACC existing. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, it's like not even just it's like foundationally,
definitionally, I hate the essence of Beckett. It's like not
really a complaint even.
>> Becket says that Becket claims it's not his essence.
Becket claims,
>> you know, I don't want to be like that. That's what
Becket says to me. Well, I'm pretty sure he doesn't want to be
a way that makes you constantly want to call him slurs, but I
don't know if he I don't know. We'd have to I >> treat
this guy like some abused woman right now.
>> You are abusive to Becket. What do you mean you are?
It might be. Listen, it might be. It might be that Becket is
like really annoying and he deserves to get like beat up sometimes.
But I'm just saying you do execute that second part. Okay. It's
dub. Well, it's I don't even know if it's up, but it's All I
see are the bruises, okay? I didn't see the original fight. All
I see are the bruises on his poor psyche, okay? It's [__]
up again
about other people >> and it is a lot. We We're like we're
not there's no preamble.
We're we're going in very hard to talk about some of their stuff
cuz I feel that there are people in this community who have been
lied to and lied about
and it's time it's time we cleared a lot of this up. Now, one
thing that you'll be aware of as well, I want to just put this
out out front. Uh I want to address some like rumors that are
kicking
So, yes,
Belgian Diesel fell out very badly.
Um, again, despite the fact that I'm close with Diesel to an
extent that I wasn't really clear on, there is like the the fallout
from some of this mod stuff has been really significant
and it's not like it's not a little thing.
Okay. Um, KJ, >> Daddy, Becky, babe, this is like old times.
It's kind of weird seeing you while streaming, but nice.
>> Oh, that is awesome. Sometimes she'll come to my chat
and drop like 10 bucks.
>> Nice. 50 seck Swedish. >> For those who don't
know, runs my clip channel. The reason he does this is because
when my channel got six copyright strikes last year and I was
like, "Oh,
there are people trying to literally chase me off the platform
for the content I make." I needed some help. And KJ, I was talking
to KJ about it. He was like, "Well, what about this? Uh, like
have you have considered a clip channel?" I was like, "I'd need
someone to actually help and do run it." He's like, "Okay, I've
got you. I'll sort you out. Um, I'll make, you know, I'll do
the work." He's done a massive amount of work
completely like unpaid just like if the channel takes off, he'll
take the revenue from it. Ash has done a hu >> how's the
channel? >> Huge amount of work.
And I,
you know, I'm looking at somebody who has done an >> You
are Jason. So, >> did you ask that same question? Did you
ask? Did you ask or >> I feel like you asked that question.
>> I didn't ask that question. No, I No, I didn't ask that
question. You're just >> Why? Wait, why? Why didn't you
ask that question? Since I'm the Could you tell me why you didn't
ask that question? >> What you mean? I don't pay my clippers.
That's for sure. >> Oh, no. I'm saying how did the I'm
saying how did the clip channel do? You didn't ask how the clip
channel's doing. >> It's a clip channel.
Yeah, I I guessed how the clip channel was doing. >> I
haven't seen any clips going around. How about you? But >> I'm
not trying to see my feed. >> I genuinely didn't know and
was willing to go. You know what? I wonder how that's doing.
You guys are like, "No, I would never ask that. I know how it's
doing. You're I'm not the You're the >> Want to help me,
>> I've I've known KJ now since the Tyler stuff
and he has been like absolutely solid through all of it.
So, I'm I'm yeah, I'm I'm very annoyed to hear the stuff that's
been said about KJ
and I feel also because I was aware of this stuff happening in
August last
I feel like I should have stepped in more.
Um maybe that's maybe that's like a little overly self-critical.
>> that's what I'm saying. If it was that big of an issue,
why didn't he? >> Yeah, I don't know. I don't know why
he didn't. What the heck?
I I feel like if this guy was really helping you and he was getting
like lied about at that point.
>> Well, I I just feel like if he was really helping you
and he was getting lied about, probably
>> would be something I'd try to step in on. That's all.
>> I I feel like I should have stepped in more. If I had
known the extent of the stuff being said about KJ, most of which
I have only discovered within the last week or so, I would have
done.
Um KJ is back on my mod team. There is there is a question of
why a few mods have left Copord. Largely this is to do with me
remoding KJ. All they know about KJ is what they've been told
behind the scenes which again is inaccurate
to say the least. Jesus.
>> I know other people have issues. I know there are friendships
tied up in this. I want to be very clear. This is a bit of an
amnesty zone cuz I don't know who has pushed things in different
directions. >> Amnesty, bro. >> I'm not >> What?
Well, it's a bit of an amnesty zone. What? What's the problem
with >> Talks about it, man.
>> He's a place. This is a channel of forgiveness right
here. Okay. >> These people should be in prison. >> It's
a channel of forgiveness. He doesn't know who's been saying what,
so he wants to grant a full amnesty. Okay. No charges will be
laid out
for these Discord DMs that went back and forth. Okay, we won't
be cutting your head off for these Discord DMs. I get it. >> Oh,
sure. >> Oh, what is it called? They're not going to necklace
you. Okay. Becket knows everything about necklacing. He's not
going to necklace you over this. Okay.
>> So, I got a different perspective.
>> Yeah, it's a different perspective. Go
certain people and we'll get to why have also apologized to me.
No one needs to.
But, you know, if people feel like they they have to move away
from the
>> I'm not holding any grudges. I'm not annoyed at anybody.
I get it. This is a massive mess that has been brewing. >> Queen
is like actually super racist about any South African that lives
in England. Anytime I've ever called somebody English and they're
South African, he's like, "No, they're South African." I'm like,
"I can't tell the difference." He's like, "Shut up. They're South
African." He's like, he's very clear. They are not British. They
are not English. >> They're South African. Okay.
>> For a significant amount of time. So, for those of you
who went like, "Why are we going over the stacks?" Like, dude,
Fali, I have spoken to Falgi
is preparing a response.
Morau is drip feeding information as is Reena. This is really
unhelpful because it's like, well, what the like, how do you
do a response to that? >> It's actually incredibly helpful
because it's very funny. Has Becket thought about that? That
it's incredibly funny that information is being fed out this
way. I don't know if he's thought about that. Why does Why does
he think so many people are here? >> Literally helping
your bottom line right >> If R just dropped everything,
it probably get litigated super quickly and and you wouldn't
get 9,000 viewers >> It wouldn't even hurt that much either.
Drop the information. Let's all have a look at it. Let FGI do
a response and let the audience decide. Stop this drip feed.
I'm sick of it. It makes it really hard to even deal with this.
Seriously. Um, and there are things here that, as I say, I do
want to deal with.
So, there you go. There's there's my preamble. I just want to
I just want to rip that band-aid right off. So, Jesus, I am so
tired, guys.
Okay,
so for those of you who were unaware, who have just come into
me ranting about this [__] and are like, "What the
is going on?"
He's He's like, "I'm sorry I had to be so harsh, guys." General
Amnesty Zone. I feel really bad that I didn't do more here. I'm
sorry I had to be so harsh and like evil to you guys. General
Amnesty
I should have stepped in earlier. I reallyed up here, guys. >> Who
is he being mean to? Who is he? >> I'm such a loser. I'm
such a guy. Several days ago, >> being so mean, guys. >> Leaks
were produced by Moral and Reena, uh, a former OP block mod and
close friend of Cloudy.
>> Um,
where Fali had been with Reena,
as well as information to do with how Cloudy and Fal were behaving
behind the scenes. Now, I had some forewarning to this because
before any of this had happened, this is like there's lots of
little popping dramas if I'm honest. there had been stuff happening
behind the scenes where I had become aware of other things happening.
So, it's kind of just been a cascade all all originating in August
of last year by the way. And we are again going to run through
the timeline now. Some of these I will be clear some >> Reena
is the ACC town bicycle or whatever. Or is Reena? Oh, >> I
don't know. Maybe maybe round's just a smooth operator. That's
>> that is that has been Gokado. Yeah, I >> don't
talk about fan wife like that. Don't talk about my my viewers's
wife like that, buddy. Okay. >> Wait, who are you talking
about?
>> The guy
honor. I got it. I got it. I got it. >> All of the stuff
that has been leaked. We are talking about like consenting adults.
We're talking about an ongoing longunning thing,
>> bro.
So, your viewer?
Um, and we should be clear. >> This guy watches just they're
just trading them around. They're just sharing around. >> This
guy's got a this guy's got a laptop. He's watching a Queenman
stream while watching,
you know, he's he's got the chair in the corner. He's got he's
got the Queen stream on, so he can't hear what's going on in
the room. What accusations we're making here? I've heard accusations
of like voyerism
um or like a gooning live. I can't see any evidence for those
things. Um, and like the [__] in a clear way that
it can be looked at and understood and not picked apart across
multiple streams.
>> Um, I'll say the same thing about I said about Vlad
and having a leaked is hilarious and it's embarrassing, but unless
there's like a deeper thing here, like it's just embarrassing.
And because of this mod stuff, because of the other stuff, uh
there are just other >> Well, I mean, this guy clearly
was trying to be manipulative about morale to at least this woman,
right? Trying to tell her Oh, and the the other oplog person,
I forget her name. Uh
>> right? Ash. Yes, that's like it was with both of them,
right? That he's like, don't mention morale. Don't be around
morale. morale >> the places that I personally am focused.
>> Okay, that that makes sense.
So yeah, um
basically this has run for a couple of days now. Um I said originally
that I wasn't going to cover this. I wasn't going to step in.
I certainly haven't gone to morale behind the scenes and been
like, "Hey buddy, why you attacking my friend dickers? Be nice
to I haven't done any of that." Um, I mean, again, they'll confirm
this.
Um, if if there's any questions,
uh, I think that I think there was something like cuz I turned
up in a gamma chat. Like, they were like, "Oh, isn't it interesting
that Beckett's turned up in the gamma chat? How does Becket know
who Gamma is?" Bro, I've collabed with Gamma. There is a gamma
video on Cam Nuggets and I am half of it.
I've known who gamma is. >> I mean, the video he did with
him probably. Yeah, but like you know why why have you put yourself
in that >> I don't know. Becca Becca collabs with everybody.
What's your theory? What are you thinking?
>> Well, I mean it I don't know. I don't have a theory.
I'm saying it's like, you know, something's clearly gone wrong.
You know who Gamma is. >> I see.
I see. Don't you hang out in Gamma's Discord a lot?
>> Don't you play Don't you play Marathon with Gamma? I'm
very I'm perfectly positioned to
make this statement.
>> Okay. Sorry. I was sent to >> the marathon gameplay
more than anything. The marathon gameplay more than anything
tells me. >> Oh, that's the way it is. >> Hold on.
I got sent a clip earlier and I never watched it. It's from last
July. >> You called them obsessed freaks. >> That
is obsessive. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Cuz it's obsessive, man. >> This dude's a dad,
bro. You are You got too much. That's not going to slow me down
at all.
Wait, is this is he talking about Fiji right now or is he talking
about somebody else? He's >> talking about Gilded Poo.
>> Oh, I see. Oh, I don't know why I got sent this mad.
This is why Fi was like
he should be mass This is a clip that made Fi say Tyler should
be mass
>> I mean, dude,
Tyler guy is crazy. >> He is crazy. To be fair, this clip
This This Yeah, he is. But this clip isn't a good reason. This
clip is a bad reason. No, this a bad reason for a mash report.
No, cuz listen to what he actually says. Play it through. Play
it through. >> Well, I'm assuming he's talking about doxing
here. If he's not talking about doxing, it's whatever. >> He's
not. No, no, no. He doesn't say anything about doxing.
>> Bro, I'm going to tell you this right now. If you want
[__] start a war, you better think of your kids.
Uh, if you if you even respond to this, cuz I will snatch the
food right out of their mouth. I'll put you on the street for
this and that's not going to You have kids in your talking like
this. That's too much risk. Understand? I will still [__]
your [__] up. You're out of your mind. Holy.
Do you talk about this? Do you talk like this about your kids,
man? Your kids friends? How the old is this guy's kids?
Talking about Oh my god. >> 15 people.
>> Jesus.
Um I mean he he's talking about basically ruining his career
by doing an expose. I guess a little different. >> sure.
Sure. Sure. Goofy, >> but for like two years. Um,
I just happened to see him covering it. For those wondering,
I guess, uh, what other rumors am I addressing? Uh, I have heard,
uh, rumors that,
uh, there was talking about me behind the scenes. This is true.
Um, I want to be really clear. Like >> this is why this
stream, okay, and the people who come on this stream are awesome
because Becket never has to worry about people keeping talk off
streams, okay? If people have problem with Becket, they just
say it very openly, very honestly. You'd always push back. You
can always disagree. All right? None of that. None of like going
to people's DMs and complaining about Becket. Nothing like that.
It's just all on the surface. You can engage with whatever you
like. Okay? Don't care. I am far more annoyed at how this has
exploded and other things than people
about me. I will say finding out that there was essentially some
kind of vent chat about me
with my mod team in it and Faldi and
is a little bit mental if I'm honest. I don't I don't really
know how to process that information.
What am I meant to do with that? Do you know what I mean? Like
>> Kman, have you reached out to Fali to get added to this
group chat so you
>> can the back of talking group chat
>> Why was I not invited? >> Well, I got lots going
for you. >> It's Am I being crazy? Is that like a weird
thing to discover about yourself? It's just like, oh, okay, cool.
>> I don't think that's I think that's really But dude,
wouldn't you be annoyed if you've got like people who you rely
on who like are sensibly your fans? you find out they've got
a group chat with people who hate you to talk you
I don't know. That would be weird. You'd assume like if they
had a huge problem with you, they'd say something directly. >> I
mean, I don't think [__] talk specifically. I think
it was a general vent chat, but he
>> and they happen to talk about it. Okay. No, that's different.
>> Now, look, look, I have said to Fouchi,
Fali and I both content creators. I've about FG to be clear.
This isn't like a like I've cuz I've had my frustrations over
the last several months. Fouchi and I have worked very closely
together. This is a normal thing you know. Um however I when
I have it's usually a things that I've said or would say to Fouchi's
face and secondly and to be clear FGI has now aired some of those
grievances with me or it's to like you know in a content creator
space it's not to like random chatters. Now one criticism that
has come back to me is that I am very distant from my mod team
and I was very distant from my mod team. I am, you know, I trust
Shadow and Hos to run this community. I have known both of them
for years. They are good at what they do and I trust them. So,
the mod team I considered theirs. And
the reason if people wonder why I am distant from chatters, why
I'm generally not in, you know, I don't I don't post in the Discord
a lot, right? I don't jump in calls very often. I've doing been
doing that a little bit more over the last week partly because
I know you know of the community drama.
But the reason I don't do that is because of dramas like this.
Because when you put yourself this close to people who are not
content creators, who do not understand
essentially how this ecosystem works, you are putting yourself
at massive risk. and Fali has put himself at massive risk over
a prolonged period of time and it has bitten him. That's just
the reality.
Um
ah okay
there's some there's a little subtext there. You know what Becket's
saying, >> Oh, sorry I didn't catch it last. I was
>> Oh um he's saying that like you It's fine. He's basically
saying there's only so long you could be around these town bikes
before you take a ride. That's that's literally what he's saying
right now. That is the core thing he is
>> come on now. >> No, go hold on. Go back and listen.
Go back and listen. That is literally what he said. >> So,
the mod team, why I am distant from chatters? Why I'm generally
>> Why is he distant from chatters? Generally, not jumping
>> NPCs. You know, I don't I don't post in the Discord
a lot, right? I don't jump in calls very often. I've been doing
that a little bit more over the last week, partly because I know,
you know, the community drama.
But the reason I don't do that is because of dramas like this.
Because when you put yourself this close to people who are not
content creators, who do not understand
essentially how this ecosystem works, you are putting yourself
at massive risk. And Fouchi has put himself at massive risk over
a prolonged period of time and it has bitten him. >> Yeah.
What do you think? He's saying something else, too. But that
was what I took away. you disagree. >> I think it's clear
what he's saying, but I see I see the read you're taking.
>> I think what he's what he's really saying is that
um as a content creator, he's friends with people who aren't
content creators and they've basically seen him as somebody who's
like as a friend, he's like betraying them. As content creators,
people would kind of expect something like this and that's what's
biting him, right? Like when he cuts all those people out from
the OP block, >> that's probably more what he's saying.
>> Sorry, I did hear it differently the first time. I like
my first interpretation way better, but it's probably not what
he was saying. So, too
>> That's just the reality.
Um, he knows
Um, that's that, you know, he he is aware.
So, yeah, me, can I have a cigarette? I feel like I'm asking
permission now. It's really It's like, dude,
I cannot stress to you how much I hate dealing with inter community
drama. I have one request. Uh, my mods are aware of this and
everyone else. Do not bring other community drama to my doorstep
that I have to deal with. It is exhausting, guys.
I thought that was literally what the stream is. Am I misunderstanding?
Is that not literally what the stream is?
I thought this like 50% of the streams was like art community
drama. These people are all art community people
and it's drama from other communities that get brought to him.
I thought that was literally what his wasn't his discord called
like parliament or something and that's like where they solve
all these problems or is that different from the coord that's
not Beckett's discord? No, that's um the liar convoy old discord
the Senate. >> No, there's a discord called Parliament
that he's referred to before. >> Oh, then that's a newer
version of the Liar Convoy Discord that's not run by Liar Convoy,
I think. >> I think that's was run by Becket. I think Becket's
the person >> I don't think it's run by Becket. I don't
think it's run by Becket.
>> Okay. All right. Maybe not. Maybe I'm misunderstanding.
In any case, I think that's where I'm going to call it for the
night, guys, is before Becket goes and gets a cigarette,
I'll copy this at the current timestamp and save it in my backlog
so I can cover it tomorrow. We'll probably do this and then maybe
the Becky Queen conversation as well tomorrow.
>> Yeah, you don't need that much that stream to be honest.
>> Yeah, I'm guessing not. Becket, is there any new information
in the Becket
>> No, the he just shows the diesel call.
All right. Well, I think that's it for us, guys. I will be back
tomorrow.
Have a good night, everyone.
See you around.
Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good
night. Good night. Sweet dreams. Bye.